My discord, my, what, my game thingy, my...
Wait, which color was that?
You got this, you got this.
Guys, I don't think we're beating Pico Park today, I don't...
We are!
No, have faith!
Guys, I don't...
Am I in red?
I'm in red, okay.
Who's Tungus green head is on my head right now?
Who is a green head?
Who the fuck is this person on my...
Oh, a fucking mid.
I have to look at my...
I'm looking at the discord overlay.
It's like, okay, orange.
Orange.
I'm looking orange.
Orange is glad I'm not yellow.
Three collabs in and we're still just calling each other based off of the color.
The color of your avatar.
Pick your words wisely, orange.
Alright.
Who was orange?
Just look at your discord overlay.
Oh yeah, I never changed it.
Okay, oh wait, that's all of us.
Wait.
No, wait, no, that's not all of us.
We're missing two.
I want to get rid of the little hats.
I don't like the little numbers.
Little hats?
What?
You can put hats on you in settings that gives you numbers, so instead of being like purple, blue, you're like one, two, three, four, five.
Yeah.
You can?
Why did you pick that?
I don't know.
I don't want to get rid of it now.
Yeah, why do you have that on?
I don't like it.
I want to get rid of it.
Oh, player number's off.
There we go.
It's in settings.
Oh, so that's cool.
Because last time I played with a different group, we couldn't figure out colors because we were all colorblind.
I think we were Christmas colorblind, so we had to change it.
Is any of us colorblind?
No.
Okay, I wouldn't care anyway, so that's fine.
There's no...
Sorry, there's no accessibility here.
We're good, we're good.
There's no...
Now we're just little guys.
Nice.
All right.
Two, four, six.
We're missing one.
Who's the last one?
Not me, man.
Is it Snuffy?
I think it's Snuffy.
Yeah, yeah, Snuffy.
Yeah, yeah.
He needed a sec.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm trying to speed it up.
You're good!
It's all right.
I wasn't the one that called you out, so it's okay.
It was a loving call out because I always notice when Snuffy isn't here because she lights up my life and the room.
Aww!
What does that say about us?
The rest...
All right, we just gotta...
Don't worry, this room is set to maximum seven, so no one extra...
Oh, perfect.
Hey, since we're one short, surely we'd be better at the game now, right?
Is that how it works?
I believe.
Yeah, because there's less people to coordinate with.
Yeah, yeah.
So then we should be...
That's optimistic.
But to be fair, Rin was one of our brain cells, so that's also an issue.
Her brain cells canceled out Amelie's brain cells, so now it's like...
We're like the damn.
Damn.
Okay, so...
We're talking against ourselves today.
We're screwed.
So, all right.
So that means everything is on Lime then.
Lime, this is it.
This is your...
No pressure there.
Your time to shine.
Lime, save us, Lime.
You almost won the Wheel of Fortune and you didn't even know the game, right?
You gotta save us.
All right, we're in.
I got you.
It's gonna be great.
Okay, start game.
All right.
Oh, look at all these things we beat, guys.
Oh, now it's time for Time Limit, everybody.
Oh, boy.
I don't know about all that.
We just got here.
What about some warm up?
Oh, you want warm up?
Okay.
These ones look fun.
Last part.
We did that one.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, let's warm up, guys.
Oh, what just happened?
Huh?
Oh.
What the?
What?
Wait, what's happening?
Oh.
It's like red light, green light.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
Oh.
We can't.
Let's go back.
You know what?
Let's go somewhere else.
This place sucks.
Yeah.
Okay.
Press space.
Press X button to use skill.
Oh.
Oh, I've become cube.
Watch it.
I can kill people.
Oh.
Space to use skill.
Oh, we just...
And then we push them.
Push them to the button so I can make you into a cube.
Oh, okay.
Oh, if you shoot someone, you become a cube.
Yeah.
And then somebody...
I become a cube.
Oh, we have to put one cube on the left side and one cube on the right.
I see.
We have to protect us.
Yeah, you're the protection.
You gotta be protection!
Be careful!
Alright, somebody has to press the button.
Okay, how do we get them out of cube form?
How do you un-cube them?
Oh, just move, okay.
Oh, just move.
It doesn't work!
Oh, it's space!
We've been hexed!
Oh, it's space, okay.
How do we get them outside?
Oh, cube on here!
Yeah, that's gonna break for sure.
I didn't know!
I was gonna die regardless.
I was on the platform.
Wait, we have to use cube people as the bridge?
Make the bridge out of people?
Oh!
Doggy!
What are you doing?
I didn't die!
You pressed the button!
Nah, you have no proof.
My lawyer says I didn't.
Just cube me.
Somebody cube before we press it!
I've been cubed, I've been cubed.
Okay, we have...
Alright, defend.
Yeah, press.
Now un-cube.
Nice.
We're a bridge.
I'm bridge one.
Who did that though, still?
Somebody cube me before I die.
Cube me first.
Maybe we have to platform across it.
Wait, hold on a second.
Do cubes maintain their height?
I think so, yeah.
So everyone just maintain...
You maintain your height.
So people have to make a bridge.
And someone's gonna hop over and get the button.
I'm stepping stone bridge.
Okay, who's good at parkour?
Who has watched parkour civilization?
Not yet.
I don't understand.
I only know something about the beef and chicken.
Yeah, beef and chicken.
Don't worry, I got this.
I watched parkour civilization the entire movie.
You can jump up this far for spacing.
Okay.
I got this.
I think we need to space it out.
We definitely got this.
We need to space a cube between the red arrows.
Yeah, yeah.
We need to space them for this key.
Alright, and then...
I'll just stay here.
Okay, and then I'll do this.
I'm gonna cube.
Okay.
I can't jump from here.
Guys, I might have watched parkour civilization, but I'm not that good.
You're our leader.
You have to walk in, bro.
There aren't enough spaces.
Yeah, yeah.
I think you two have to spread out.
Spread out a little bit.
Does the key fall?
We just need to get the key.
We don't have to care about this.
The key will fall, so someone has to be underneath it.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I don't think we need this.
We don't need...
I don't think you need to be here, because we just need to get the key.
I can just press the button from here.
No, no, no.
Because once the button's pressed, I'm not sure...
How do we make it?
The blocks might fall.
We'll test it out.
How do we...
When we unbox, what do we do?
Maybe it's a timer.
Okay, let's find out.
Yeah, let's find out.
Somebody needs to be on top of a cube.
I cannot shoot you for some reason.
There we go.
That's a pretty big jump.
Okay, good luck.
Wait, are we letting...
Wait, we're letting...
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
She's going for the key!
Okay, now what?
Wait, wait, wait!
What if you go back?
What if you go on the other side?
Oh, that's true.
Is there another button?
Risk it all just to find out!
Oh my god!
She's going for the key!
Doki, I think you're going to have to move a little bit.
Don't worry, I got you guys.
Oh my god.
I can't move anymore.
Doki, get the beef!
Okay, now what?
There's no beef.
Oh, okay.
I guess you could just do that.
I wanted Doki to die with me.
Jump just in time!
Okay, okay.
I think...
Okay, and we got...
What if we use the...
The boxes as shields?
For the spikes?
So they don't damage the bridge.
Oh, is it the spikes that break the bridge?
Oh, it might be.
Whoa!
Look at that!
Our brains...
Maybe we're just mourning brain cells.
Maybe we should clean in the morning.
This is our warm up.
It's like game one.
Okay, okay.
You're going to defend that and then...
Alright, we're all safe.
Alright, let's go.
Find an arrow!
Parkour civilization, let's go!
Get under the spike!
Oh my god, we're so smart.
Okay.
That was good.
Somebody shoot me!
I think, Mint, you need to be slightly to the right.
To the right, okay.
Wait, who are we?
Alright, Snuffy, do you want to...
Alright, Snuffy, are you ready to be the parkour person?
I was just...
I was realizing that this technique, you have to catch the key, right?
No, there's still one more!
There's still one more arrow!
The bridge won't break.
Oh, okay.
Just that one, on the right.
No, I believe in you, Snuffy.
Just don't go for the beast.
Just don't go for the beast, Snuffy.
What if he needs to be a box?
Shoot me!
You're so close!
You're so close to me!
Jump!
Jump and shoot!
I have to jump to the other side!
You have to jump regardless!
Yay!
It worked!
We did it!
Oh my god.
We over thought that one a lot, I think.
Yeah, we did not do the parkour.
We deserved that.
We tried really hard.
I think we big brained it the first time.
Honestly, yeah.
Let's just keep going.
We're 14.
We got this.
We got this coming.
Oh, this is it.
Oh, it's whack-a-mole!
There's more people!
Oh, we got whack seven!
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, that's fine.
We don't die.
There's big ones!
Watch out to not get hit, I think.
We don't die though.
Oh!
I need a second person to help!
Oh, he's gone.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh, I'm kinda bad at this.
Who's yellow?
Not me.
Wow.
We need to do it in a row.
Get it.
Do we have to time this?
You need to come back over here first.
It's in a row.
So we need to perfectly do this one first.
Whose corpse is on me?
Someone get blue!
Someone get that one!
Get the girl!
Oh, no!
Okay, one, two, three, four...
Help!
Red!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
One more!
Okay, one.
Okay, we got this.
Look, we're learning how to count.
Okay, now double.
Okay, we both used our cooldown!
We both used our cooldown!
Okay, got it, got it.
I got it, I got it.
Good job, everybody.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Everyone should be on a trampoline.
Okay, guys.
Guys, pick one.
One at a time, everybody.
Oh, god.
I got my man.
My little guy.
Okay, I got my little guy.
I got my guy here, too.
You go ahead.
If you want to head over.
Okay.
Alright.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
Yes, man.
I almost.
Okay.
Orange, can you go to the next one?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
I got you.
Got him.
Alright.
We're doing the countdown.
Do the countdown thing.
Oh.
Okay.
I guess we just need to speed them up.
I'm pretty sure we do this all at once, don't we?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
All at once?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do we have to... Oh, what's the...
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
The countdown.
Three, two, one.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Next one?
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Let's wait.
We can coordinate this.
Okay.
The moment it goes up, we punch it.
Okay?
Okay.
I thought on the next...
Okay, on the next... No, I'm weird.
Okay, on the one...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
The next one.
Hit!
Oh, so close!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Stop it.
Stop it, stop it, stop it.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Next one.
This one, this one.
Right here.
One.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
The one after this.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Two.
One.
Go!
Wait, who is it?
That was me.
Hold on, hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm ready for the next one.
One.
Go!
No!
I pressed my button even though it was in the wrong place.
Three, two, one.
Go!
I missed it.
How did you miss it?
Three, two, one.
Yes!
Go!
Yay!
We got stuck!
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's all of us.
We all have to punch it.
Yeah, we do have to punch it.
I think we all have to punch it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Punch them.
We have to like...
Stack, yeah.
Stack, stack.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on, let me just...
Is it over?
I'm getting over?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't get hit by him.
Oh, nice.
Wait, what?
Oh, do it again, do it again.
Oh, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it.
We looked at it.
We're just like, what happened?
Nice, okay.
Yay!
It was so easy.
Oh my god, the single brain cell working overtime.
I love that there's ping in the left corner.
Has anyone seen that?
Oh my god.
Why is that not relevant?
Why is the ping relevant in Niko Park?
Because people gotta complain, blame it on something.
Guys, my ping is like 50 right now.
I don't know if this is playable.
It's blocked then.
Shoot me.
Okay.
Everybody box up.
Minus one dent.
Guys, alright.
Who's ready to shoot me?
We need box hats.
Okay, get right here.
Okay.
We need to wear each other.
I'll bait the thing.
We gotta bait it.
Okay, watch this.
Okay, not that.
Okay, never mind, let's just do hats.
Wow, what?
Why?
I thought you guys needed...
Okay, one person will have no hat.
But that's okay.
Okay, actually...
Oh, we can't.
You can't wear them.
Okay, I baited it.
Okay, I still touched it.
What did you do?
I ran against it.
I stubbed my toe.
Okay, watch this.
There you go.
There, just don't stub your toe.
Okay.
Okay, but then what do we do after?
Oh my god.
What do we do after?
Wait, it'll stop on it, right?
Like, we can just keep walking, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So I was like, what?
And then we have someone at the end Somebody got impatient.
Guys, guys!
Oh!
It was me!
I jumped.
I was trying to shoot Doki.
Okay.
Dukes, dukes.
Somebody shoot her.
Okay, nice.
Alright, now everybody just walk underneath.
Don't get impatient, guys.
Wait, wait, wait.
Somebody should go here now so they have all the time in the world to walk.
Oh!
Bro, how?
I appreciate the sacrifice.
We go in the ladder.
I scream.
It'll happen!
Okay, okay, okay.
I just needed to get my brain matched.
Easy!
I'm good, I'm good.
This is a good lobotomy.
Okay, okay.
Alright, someone get on me and become cu- Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright, we go forward.
Now someone become a cube down here.
Okay, um...
Shoot.
Ah!
You have to say something!
Shoot!
I said shoot.
That was enough.
We need a Doki death counter.
What did I do?
That was my first death.
That was my first death right there.
Okay, okay.
Okay, become cube.
I'm scared!
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, cube death.
Sorry, wait.
Wait, Val.
There we go.
Okay.
Wait, I can't go under!
We're stuck!
Wait!
You guys are stuck!
I have to save you guys!
I was saving everyone!
I'm a hero!
I'm a hero.
I'll save you, Doki!
Wait, I'm out!
Okay, shoot me.
There we go.
Okay.
Now someone becomes a cube.
Now that I'm so far away, you can't blame me.
Are you ready to shoot?
Do you have your finger on the trigger?
Are you ready?
We have one chance.
Go, go, go!
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And now I don't fuck it up!
See!
It wasn't me!
I literally stood there and did nothing!
I was literally about to say, now I don't fuck it up!
Alright.
Who's gonna shoot?
Are you ready?
I got it.
I don't think they were ready, guys.
I need one second.
One second.
I'm gonna make a fucking difference.
Oh, wait.
How did she die?
You got shot with a real gun!
What happened?
I'm telling you, there's I had a fucking aneurysm.
Alright, don't worry.
We got this.
I believe...
Okay, who's gonna...
I'm gonna be here so you guys can't...
Oh, no.
Just keep funneling into the...
Alright, I'm gonna stay in here so nobody can blame me.
It's not my fault if I'm all the way here.
Okay, nice.
Go, go, go, go.
Get your blocking butt out of the way.
Okay.
Not me.
Okay, ready?
What if I unblock right now?
Okay.
Stay right.
Just stay right there.
Okay.
Get up, get up, get up.
Nice, nice, nice.
What do we do here?
Is this...
We got a parkour.
It's real stiff now.
Oh, it is.
It's parkour.
No, no, no.
Don't say that.
Okay, and then...
Do we make a bridge?
Somebody has to...
Okay, who has a good shot?
I'm gonna go up.
I'm gonna jump.
Okay, never mind.
What do you mean you're gonna jump?
We're gonna make a bridge.
Okay, who wants to make...
Oh yeah, there is a ledge over there.
Somebody shoot.
Somebody shoot the staircase.
Which one?
I think we can shoot...
I feel like we need our platform a little longer.
Can we make like a platform?
Like a human platform?
Oh, maybe.
We'll all fall though, right?
Okay, maybe we shoot bow and then we can...
And then we can...
Can we climb?
Yeah, yeah, we can...
Yeah, but if we freeze people over the gap then they die when they...
They can't come back, right?
I think that's the key.
I think that's where the key is.
We just need to grab the key on the other side.
But there's no way you can make this jump because there's like...
There's like a platform right above us.
Maybe if someone steps off and then as they're falling we shoot?
Yeah.
Oh, maybe.
Alright, if we all three of us shoot then we'll hit...
One of us will hit her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Do a countdown.
Okay, ready?
No, we're never getting her back.
We are never getting her back.
She is gone.
She's not coming back.
Don't hate me, but I'm going to test something.
I'm going to test something.
We are going to test something.
Oh my God!
Yeah!
We timed it so well.
Okay.
This is so easy then.
Wait, we need someone to block over there.
Someone will jump and turn you into a cube.
No, just kidding.
Okay, no.
We did it.
Stop killing me!
I don't wanna be cute!
Okay, somebody has to...
Okay, awesome.
Thank you, Doki.
Oh, there's more.
We have to get everyone over?
Okay, somebody has to give me a platform.
No, I like the way we...
How do we become cubes?
There we go, yay!
Just come back when you feel like it.
Doki, can you jump?
Wait, why me?
Can you just come to my platform?
Okay.
Now it's your turn to jump.
I didn't miss.
There you go.
You have to time that shit.
How do you do the timer?
A tab and it's at the very bottom.
Okay, you gotta jump.
We may not have left ourselves with enough people.
It's fine.
Okay, wait, wait.
Keep jumping.
Why is Bao on the way over there?
Cause we needed that extra platform.
No, you don't!
I did.
Oh, we need one more.
Yeah, yeah.
I think about...
Okay.
I told you.
No, it's cause we don't need those two blocks close to each other.
You got this.
Okay.
Alright, now we gotta figure this out again.
Alright, shoot.
Wait, I can't.
I can pick up.
Nice.
And then what?
And then jump.
Okay, we gotta make one extra platform then.
I'll do it closer.
How about here?
Yeah!
And then we just need one person to make it through.
I need...
Okay, I need you to shoot me.
I think.
You shoot me, you shoot me.
What?
Shoot you?
Well, you need to get off my head.
Actually, you know what?
You can do whatever you want.
I'll shoot you.
I missed.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Wait, we have...
Maybe we just push this closer.
No, no.
Okay, I was gonna say.
We can push Lime closer.
What's up?
Just chillin'.
Jump and shoot.
I'm sorry.
Three, two, one.
Go!
Wait, why did you jump?
I don't know.
I was trying to get it high.
Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry.
You got this.
Yay!
Okay.
Okay, you gotta do here.
Alright, get over here.
And then...
You actually didn't need that extra person after all.
Go, go, go.
We did it!
Ain't no way, bro.
Ain't no way.
I think we should freeze Amelie right here.
Yeah, we have Amelie.
Amelie, you're good.
Amelie, don't go there.
Alright, Amelie.
You stay right there, Amelie.
Amelie, don't move.
Amelie, did you play Pico?
Amelie.
You know the worst part?
Amelie has the most experience in Pico Park 2 out of all of us.
How many hours?
How many hours do you spend?
What's your ping at?
Yeah, what's your ping?
What's your ping?
I think I know who...
Who's the reason why we have a ping difference.
Yeah.
I don't get out of the way of the door, so I don't be in the door's way.
I don't block the door from the key person.
There are tears of pain in my eyes right now.
Tears of pain.
You don't understand.
There are tears of pain.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Here we go again.
Does that work?
No, okay, I don't want me to...
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
I was too far.
It's so over.
I'm just gonna stay here.
You know what?
Thanks for inviting me here.
What are you doing?
Who do they blame?
The team or do they blame the coach?
Shoot!
Oh, okay.
That works.
Doki, come on.
I'm heading over.
I don't want people to blame me.
If I don't move, if I don't do anything, you can't fucking blame me.
Okay, who's gonna...
Ready?
On the next one.
Oh.
Guys, we give her nothing.
I'm not doing anything.
I'm gonna become the Joker.
You stay here.
This is your time out corner.
I'm gonna start barking.
I was crazy.
They put me in a room full of blocks.
Why are you moving?
I'm leaving you.
Go over there.
Wait, who's hot?
That works too.
I'll be hot.
Shoot me!
Okay, Amelie, come over.
Come here, Amelie.
Come over here.
Don't jump.
Amelie, get over here.
Amelie, get into this corner.
Amelie, I need you in this corner.
Okay, there you go.
Give me a box.
We should get closer.
Okay.
Nice.
It's okay.
She's a box.
She can't do no harm.
Amelie, you're the first box.
Get over here.
You're gonna be the first box.
Move.
Go on.
Are you ready?
I think we should give her the key so she doesn't walk further than the door.
Okay, but then what if she... Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Okay, Amelie, get over here.
You're not the box anymore.
Alright, here you go.
You stay here.
Look at the thing.
It's not moving now.
We're perfectly unstuck together.
Yay!
Yes!
Okay, one of us has to shoot.
Amino acids are the building blocks of the...
Okay.
...of our soul.
Oh, nice shot!
Alright, we just need one more person over here.
Two people.
We need two people.
I'm on my way.
Okay, Amelie, get up.
Okay, stop there.
Stop there, Amelie.
Stop there.
Jump on my head.
Nothing can go wrong.
Okay, you need to jump a little bit.
Me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
No, we actually...
Do you need me?
We need two people.
Yeah.
So you guys have to unbox and then try and figure out a better platform.
Wait, wait, wait.
Can you jump on the...
Oh, wait, never mind.
Here, can someone shoot me?
Oh, shoot you?
Okay, okay.
There we go.
Oh, wait, can you reach...
You can shoot me.
I think that's maybe a bit high.
Maybe a bit high.
Oh, there we go.
That's fine.
Okay.
Alright, Amelie, you go up.
Amelie, you go up on me and then there we go.
And then you go on top of...
There we go.
We did it!
Redemption!
Wait, stop.
Stop moving.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
I'm not...
Nobody is going past this door.
Wait.
Bow.
Don't go.
Don't do it, Snuffy.
Don't do it.
You know what?
We can all cue me.
I was taking permanent effect.
I was like becoming the cube.
She was full cube.
But I just kept staring at the cube.
Oh, my God.
Bow.
Be careful.
You're going to die.
You're driving the car.
You're driving the car, doggie.
Oh.
I fucked it up.
Please help me, bro.
Oh, sorry.
I thought I was on the bottom again.
Okay.
Guys.
I think the person on the bottom just has to run.
Yeah, just run on the bottom.
Oh, that's me.
Don't move.
Only punch.
Everyone else has to punch.
We're at like an angle.
Oh, my God.
He can punch too.
We have to kill him.
We gotta get closer.
Okay.
That's a little bit too close.
We were so close.
Dude, do we gotta jump?
No, we would just fall to our death.
Okay.
No, no, no.
We just turn and punch at him.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
This is good.
This is a good formation.
Get us a little closer.
What is the range of our pocket?
That's scary.
He's gonna hit us.
Oh.
Are we getting hit by the block up top?
I didn't see.
No, no, no.
He punches too.
But the only way we're close enough to him is if he's close enough to us.
The person on the bottom is gonna have to time it so they run forward when the punch happens and then run back when it's not happening.
You don't go faster though.
You can't run fast enough.
Oh, shit.
Well, okay.
We tried.
One punch.
We all have to jump over him.
Or into the hole.
Yeah.
Let's just only get close to his fist.
We fell off.
31 hits on him.
That wasn't me.
Okay.
I'm just gonna die.
Dude, we can fall.
We can fall.
I think we should get behind him.
So we can get behind him.
Get behind him.
I don't think so.
That was a good idea.
Can you punch his punch back?
Can the person who's in line with his punch We have to get all 31 punches before he does.
We have to get all 31 punches before he does.
Oh, we were doing it.
I think it's the people that are on the lower side.
It's the people up front.
Only the person at top has to punch.
Only the people at top punch and the lower people.
We make room for the fist.
Does it go down?
Does the 31 punch counter go down?
Yeah.
So it's just only one person.
I bet you were gonna run out of room.
Don't say that.
We have so much room.
Look at that.
That's why I think everybody has to be perfectly lined up.
Oh no.
We're running out of room.
I think people in line with his punch should see if you can punch when his punch comes forward.
So we have to like...
You need to back up.
We need to be like...
Like perfectly straight.
I thought I could take it.
Can you guys be perfectly straight for me?
Be perfectly straight for me, okay?
I know it's gonna be really hard.
That's never possible for me.
Yeah, there you go.
I think the ladder was the best option we had.
Yeah.
It's hard because if the person below you moves, you even get slightly put off.
So we have to be perfect.
We just gotta not fuck it up, I think.
I think he's dragging...
Yeah, I think the ladder...
Like the bottom three cannot be close to him.
Okay.
Yeah.
So stagger forward and then the...
I think we have to move closer.
Do we have to sink back and forth?
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
The lower people have to move forward towards him when his fist is back.
That seems kinda hard because if one person falls off, the ladder is just gone.
It's completely gone.
Just don't fall off.
Just don't fall off, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
See?
No pressure.
No pressure, guys.
We got it.
So the person second to the lowest has to just kinda move, which is me again, so I'll show you.
Oh god, I'm bottom.
It's alright.
It's fine.
People above me just don't move, so I have to go like this, dodge them, and then...
We said to have a little bit of a ladder, though.
I think the people up top are going to need to adjust so you're gonna have to move, unfortunately.
I got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this.
I believe in you guys.
Push!
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
Okay, we don't got this.
Hmm...
What is this boss level shit?
I got you guys.
Alright, thank you.
Don't be afraid.
Oh my god!
I got you guys!
That was neat.
He doesn't seem like it!
Guys, I got you guys.
Can we get behind him?
Wait, let's see if we can time it.
No, we can absolutely not get behind him.
No, no, he's way too chonky.
He's way too chonky.
Okay.
Oh hey again, kids.
Alright, don't worry, I got the timing.
Buckle the fuck up.
Oh, what?
What happened?
Something just jumped out of my head.
I was waiting for you to go.
Don't worry, I got the timing.
Don't worry, I got the timing for sure.
Oh!
This is good, this is good.
This is so messed up.
This is fucking hard.
Okay, this time we got this.
I believe in us.
Oh!
We kind of have the hang of it.
Kind of, sort of.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know about this.
If we were in the same positions, it would be okay.
Yeah, I agree.
I'm not gonna move.
I think people at the top don't have to move.
It's only the people at the bottom that have to move.
Okay.
Are you serious, Maya?
This is my first time.
Have mercy.
Okay.
Yeah, I think when the ladder is going like...
really close, it means that when we dodge, it's fucking aside.
Okay, we're good, we're good.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're doing it, we're doing it.
You're so smart, we literally almost had him.
I hit him every single time.
Guys, I didn't hit him.
I was just...
Did anybody even miss?
I didn't hit him at all.
You can't afford a single miss.
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh, god.
Are you guys okay?
Yeah, we're okay.
I'm just gonna keep running.
We had it, we had it.
We're doing it, we're doing it, we're doing it.
We're doing it for you.
We don't move, people at the top don't move.
We don't move.
Just the people in the middle.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
We got this though, we got this.
For you.
I don't like to be a bottom.
This is the moment.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, punch.
Nice.
Punch.
We were so close.
We were too close to him, I think.
People at the top stopped moving so close to him.
It's fucking up how much room we have.
Oh, no.
This pressure.
I think we can do it.
Literally the person on the bottom is the only one.
The second to the bottom.
No, Pink, I think you had to move there too because I hit you, I think.
The bottom three?
It's the second and third.
Oh, God.
I think it's second and third.
Yeah.
I just scoot up.
Am I too far away?
Yeah.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, too far.
We got this.
I believe in you.
Okay, maybe not.
Guys, maybe we should stop believing.
Okay, okay.
This is it.
I believe.
Okay, I walked as far as I could.
Remember when he had three health, bro?
Okay, okay.
Where am I?
Okay, here we go, top.
Thank God.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, no, we shifted to too much.
Oh, God.
Why doesn't it change position?
Keep us the same.
I know.
It's so rude.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
When Jibber did boo, I was like...
Oh, no.
Okay, this time for sure.
This time for sure.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Wumpus, wumpus.
That wasn't me, that wasn't me.
That was me, that was me.
Okay, yay.
I don't have to move except for punch.
Goodbye, dude.
People at the top have it good.
Oh, my God.
Good start, good start.
Nice, just keep punching.
Oh, looks close enough, I don't think.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
We're good, we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, baby.
Easy.
Oh, my God.
We figured it out, we figured it out.
It's just too easy.
We're so good at video games, guys.
Oh, my God.
Hello.
Me when the game is good.
I think Val's having a stroke right now.
We did 14.
Yay.
We made it.
All right, back to time limit.
That was awesome.
Oh, my God.
Now we got a time limit here.
Oh, no, I don't want that.
That's level five.
Oh, it's coins, it's coins.
Oh, no, the coins.
Do it, dude, do it, dude.
Beautiful coins.
I'm gonna get over here, get over here.
I'm gonna use your head.
Two beautiful people.
Guys, I don't think...
I'm heading over here.
Yes.
Don't worry.
I'm heading to the other side.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
On the other side.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Don't jump because then...
The last person can just fall and get those.
Where's the key?
Get the key, get the key, get the key.
Wait, guys, we're not...
Guys, we're not gonna make it.
Guys, we're not productive.
You just gave up.
Stop it.
Guys, what is nihilism?
It's like in a fucking zombie movie when someone just decides to execute everybody because they don't have anything anyway.
I was like, it's over.
We are just gonna fight it.
Get these back.
Guys, we have to get to the platform.
Come here, come here.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it, guys.
I don't...
Stop it, please.
Someone wait in the middle where the key is.
I got it, I got it.
I will not fall into existential despair.
Okay, go, go, go, go.
Move, move, move, move, move.
All I'm saying, all I'm saying is that I was right.
I was right.
So what happened was...
Okay, right side, right side, right side first.
Oh, I'll come down.
I'll come down, I'll come down, I'll come down.
Okay, left side first, I guess.
We can get this one, too.
Goodbye.
Get the top first.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Guys.
Are you guys okay over there?
Yeah, we were getting the coins.
There's coins we have to get.
We all know slow and steady wins the race, right guys?
Okay.
Everybody get out of the way.
Oh, no.
Go, go, go, go.
Get out of the way.
Okay, go, go, go.
It feels impossible.
Okay.
I'm grabbing the top part.
Left, left, left.
Here we go.
Let's just preemptively wait.
Somebody come down here with me.
All right, right side, right side.
Okay, guys.
We need one more on the way.
We need one more.
Nice.
This is the fastest we've ever got.
Emily, why aren't you getting those coins above you?
Somebody get the key.
Get ready.
All right.
We're ready.
Get the key.
Get out of the way.
Stay on top.
All right.
One at a time.
Nice.
Go, go, go, go.
Yeah.
Look at that.
So easy.
They should have given us less time.
That was way too much.
I don't know about all that.
Push, push, push.
Push.
What's going to happen?
Something going to fall from the sky?
I think we're just going to die.
I think we got to jump.
Wait.
Oh, we have to push to the other side.
There's no key.
What do you mean?
We have to go to the other side.
We have to go to the other side and push.
I think it might not have a key.
No, no.
I think it's on this side.
I don't think so.
Please believe in me.
I think you just have to push the box away from the door.
There should be a key.
There's always a key.
But there's always a key.
What if it's behind the block?
I don't know.
We didn't even try though.
We didn't even try before we got sabotaged.
That's true.
Let's just see.
I told you.
Nobody believed in me.
Okay, okay.
Get in there.
Push it.
Nobody believed in me.
We have to keep pushing.
We have to push the blocks.
Push the blocks and hit the buttons.
And then we have to go up top.
Excuse me.
Come here.
Call me a liar.
I think we need that box.
Oh, there's the key.
Oh, nice.
Let's go.
Run.
I don't think we can do it, bro.
I don't think so.
We totally got this.
We got this.
I will always believe in us.
Push in.
Jump on my head.
I can't make it.
We need that box.
We need that box from the other side.
There was that one box on the far left.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go, guys.
See that box?
It's right on top.
We gotta get that one box.
The little one?
We do not need as many people down there.
I was here first, guys.
I was here first.
You want one more?
Just one here?
My head is for you.
Alright, we need one more here.
And then we need...
We need four.
Okay, we need to push that box down.
Yeah, push that box.
And then we'll just push the other one.
And then I'll push this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get the key.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
And then one of us push that.
Oh, god.
Okay.
And then we just keep pushing.
Don't worry, I will keep pushing you so it looks like...
You can push two boxes at the same time.
Don't worry, it looks like we're going faster.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go, there we go.
I don't know if we're gonna make it, but we got this track down.
I think we can make it.
Alright, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Oh, yeah, no, we can't make it.
We need the key.
Three on the second bottom.
Two on the second bottom.
Guys, we figured it out, we figured it out.
I'm gonna jump on you, Belle.
Go, Belle.
Alright, here we go.
Go, go, go.
We need more people upstairs.
Go, go, go, go.
Use my head, use my head.
Somebody use my head.
All bottoms.
And push that box down.
Push the box.
Put it on my head and then I can carry it.
True, true, true.
Guys, guys, I can't get the key.
Guys, guys, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay, that box has to be...
Push.
Oh, my God.
She got like a fucking heart attack right there.
There we go.
Go, go, go, go.
I didn't realize this was a social deduction game.
Look at us over here.
Okay, we got this.
I believe in us.
Jump, jump, jump.
Our chungus lives, bro.
We're too thick.
Because we're not all the main character.
One of us has to be the side character, guys.
One of us has to be the side character.
Run, run with the block, Annie.
Okay, nice.
Now put it on their head and run with it.
Okay, go, go, just run.
Just run.
Push the block without you.
Push, push, push.
Eve, ho.
Go, go, go, go.
Everyone back up, back up, back up.
Everyone back up.
Go, go, go, go.
Get this off of me.
Let's
figure this out.
Guys, stop sucking.
We got more.
Okay, I need someone to suck me here.
Get on my head.
Guys, someone suck me off.
I'm sucking.
Get on my head.
Guys, that doesn't help.
I wish we could, but we're stuck down here.
Please, I need somebody to suck me off.
There we go, okay.
Guys, we're supposed to go to the other side.
Wait, how do you push?
Thank you.
Oh, wait.
Like that?
Alright, it's great that Lime and Amelie are doing everything for us while we stay here.
Yeah, go get them, Tiger.
We're sort of confused.
You suck the front, I suck the back.
I died.
I'm doing what I love, okay?
Left and right.
Left.
I'm at the left side.
Left side.
I'm trying to go home.
I'm at soup.
Okay.
Wait.
Hop on my head.
Okay.
Guys, that works.
That works.
Okay.
We got it.
Nice.
Up.
Suck here.
And then push me forward.
Jump.
Push me forward.
Amelie.
There we go.
Yay.
Can I ask for a little suck?
Just a little.
Oh, whatever.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Don't worry.
I got you guys.
I got you.
Suck.
Alright, now suck.
Alright, there you go.
Yeah, thank you.
I'm sorry.
Yay.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Okay, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Get the key.
I can start sucking.
I need help.
I need help, man.
Stop.
We need to suck Snuffy.
Please.
Oh.
Not again.
Wait.
Oh, what?
They disappear.
Oh, they're all gone.
Oh, you can put them all inside.
Oh, I can absorb Doki balls.
Oh, my gosh.
We've been simplified.
We're like magical.
We're dolling this.
Oh.
Oh, and then you suck us.
Guys, guys.
Bring us back in.
Guys, I need you.
Okay, here.
Here we go.
What do I have?
And then somebody put me in.
There we go.
Somebody put me in the mouth.
Excuse me, Bao.
Excuse me.
There we go.
Okay.
I got stuck not where I am right now.
We can uncompress over here.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now, I need to get let.
I need to let Lyme out.
Alright.
Oh, sorry, guys.
Try it.
You have to hold it in one.
Oh, no, you don't die.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm just gonna... I'll just be like your...
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Don't dart me, Bao.
Why did you...
No!
No, it's okay.
We don't die.
We just have a time limit of, like, not a lot of time.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'm being carried.
I love this.
Carry me, Bao.
Uh-oh.
Okay, I think...
I got this.
Oh, hey, guys.
Oh, no.
The perpetual...
The way I got this, too.
Oh.
My whole motion machine.
Okay, I think we put us all into one.
Someone gather us all.
Yeah, I got...
Oh, my God.
We got all of us up into one ball.
And then... We're not enough time.
And then I just... We got practice now!
Okay.
Good practice, team.
Good practice, guys.
Don't worry.
We practiced our aim.
I got you.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Okay.
Perpetual fall.
We were so close.
So low.
Oh, boy.
Okay.
I have compressed all my friends.
Stay there.
That was the sound of me being compressed, by the way.
Okay.
I'm compressing over here.
Somebody compress me.
Nice.
All right.
I wish to be compressed.
Somebody put me in their mouth right now.
Yeah.
Someone put me in their Pokeball.
Okay.
Now, poop them out over there.
Nice aim.
Everybody was moving.
People were moving.
I couldn't focus.
Can we get our FPS players up in here, please?
FPS players have one fucking job.
Look.
I have like 90 ping, guys.
I have 90 ping.
Okay.
Ping div.
Wait.
What the fuck?
I was so close.
Wait.
What happened to me?
Get on my head now.
Get on my head.
Fuck.
I'm out.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
If you guys get all into one, it'll be just one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's put all of each other into one right now.
All of us into one.
I can't.
I have red on me.
So, Min has to suck.
Orange?
Orange and white?
It's really, really cozy because I haven't played in a while.
Because I've just been carried around like Doki.
Alright.
That's fine.
Three people.
We got this.
That's three chances.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, guys.
I'll catch you this time.
Hold on.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, I spat my guy out.
Aw, man.
I got...
I got caught.
Hey, what's up?
That's actually so hard.
I know.
Wait.
Who has the lowest ping?
I have 27 ping.
But I'm not reliable alone.
That's crazy.
I'm not reliable, please.
I should've never said anything.
Put that on my head.
Alright.
Nice.
I don't think we got...
Oh, sorry.
Close.
Close, close.
I believe in you.
We just need one person on the other side.
Sorry.
Very good.
Nice.
Okay.
Now we suck each other.
Here.
Okay.
I got someone here.
Here.
Somebody get me.
OK.
I'll keep them in my mouth.
Huge.
Do your best.
You got one shot.
I overestimated a little bit.
I think you can fire it right as you jump off.
It feels like that.
Yeah, maybe.
It's okay, we got 40 whole seconds.
It's easy.
So close.
I got you.
Oh, we got it!
I did it!
Oh my god!
Just keep hitting.
Nice,
nice, nice, nice.
Spit, spit, spit.
Spit, spit, spit, spit.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Guys, you just hit to me one person.
Why did you all spit each other out?
I don't know.
You just hit to me one person.
Wait, no.
Sometimes when you miss, the person gets like reformed.
That out, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, consume me, okay.
I pretty much haven't played this level.
Oh, it's Duffy.
Duffy, consume me.
Take me with you.
Okay, there you go.
Well, you guys can take... yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh wait, it's Amelie.
Oh, I mean...
What is that?
What is that supposed to mean?
Amelie over here.
No, it's Amelie.
Who said that?
What is that?
I mean, there aren't any saw blades or spikes, so it's probably fine.
Sorry.
What?
I totally made that one.
Okay.
Guys, you guys don't need to spit out...
Guys, don't need to spit people out, guys.
Yeah.
Consume me.
Consume.
You guys suck somebody.
Okay, there you go.
All right, you guys have got this.
Okay.
You've got this.
Bow, Bow, we need you to bow.
We cannot be in perpetual motion right now.
No!
I got you, Doki.
Ah!
Okay, I totally got this.
I got you, Doki.
Yay!
Nice, nice, nice!
All right, spit Doki out.
Nice.
Okay, I got three people.
It's just me.
No pressure.
Oh, no.
It's actually so bad.
Okay.
It's so bad.
Please.
Okay,
Amelie's...
Okay.
No pressure.
No pressure, guys.
Okay.
Amelie went to the bathroom on a time.
Oh, yeah.
I think we're just...
Can you suck her up?
Just suck her up.
Why did none of us suck her up?
She was literally AFK.
I can't push anybody back.
Fire me back over.
I can't.
Holy carrier.
What the heck?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Why did none of us suck up the AFK person?
We can't.
None of us can spit her out.
None of us can.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Yeah, she's gonna go to the bathroom.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Restart level.
Okay, potty break.
Potty break.
Does anyone actually have to go?
Meow.
I'm actually kind of losing it.
The music I'm gonna hear is my fucking nightmares.
I fucking turned it off immediately, bro.
Is there a way?
Hold on.
There's no way to turn just the music off.
Okay.
No, there is.
It's just you probably had to have done it from the menu.
Oh, in the main menu?
Gotcha.
Well, I guess I'll just fucking suffer then.
That's fine.
Yep.
You suffer now.
Yay!
My Amazon order.
BRB.
Yippee!
Mmm.
Okay, okay, I'm back.
I'm back.
We now know that it takes you exactly the length of the 5-4 level to piss.
Welcome back.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki also went to pee.
Yeah, Doki, we can suck her up.
It takes Doki to pee.
It won't let me shoot her.
Hold on.
I'll shoot her there.
There we go.
Okay, let's go.
Wait, this totally works out.
Oh, sorry, Bao.
Wait, I need to suck...
Yeah, wait.
Juniper needs to suck someone.
Juniper?
Oh, okay, hold on.
But I need to keep Doki.
Wait.
Can someone suck me?
I'm sucking, I'm sucking, I'm sucking.
There we go.
And I'll grab Doki.
Little passenger princess.
Okay.
I cannot suck.
It's like too close.
Oh, we need someone who's active to go in there.
I've been consumed.
Oh, nice.
Sorry.
Oh, thank you.
Big difference.
You can grab me.
It's hard, dude.
Oh, what?
What the?
How did that even happen?
Thank you.
There's such a fucking delay on it.
I don't want to be in this mortal plane.
This is the fastest, I guess.
Yay!
I did it!
I've never seen one.
Yay!
I got you.
Did you just block me?
I don't know.
Guys, we're missing like one person still.
Oh, there you go.
We got, we got, we got, we got.
This is a practice round.
Trust.
Oh, we did it!
I was trying!
I was serious!
We got it on the first try.
Okay.
That's fine.
Alright, you consume me.
I consume you.
Somebody consume me.
No, I can let you through.
Right?
There you go.
Alright.
Okay, who else is AFK?
Don't shoot me through!
Don't shoot me back!
Why did you do that?
We're doing it backwards.
Oh, where am I?
Let me in!
Okay, somebody shoot me in.
Somebody consume me.
Okay, alright, there you go.
Nice!
Alright.
Okay.
That felt kind of personal.
It was not.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Alright, consume each other.
We just needed as few people as possible.
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, there you go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Both got this.
Alright, consume each other.
Consume, consume.
Oh, so close.
I think actually the most people spitting people out here is probably the odds are in our favor.
No, there'll be too many people.
Oh my god!
I don't know who that was.
Who the fuck took me back in there?
I know who that was.
There we go, okay.
Who took me back in?
No idea.
Why is nobody jumping?
I'm gonna try.
You too, Dokie!
Get in there!
Oh, am I out?
I'm out.
Hold on.
Am I out?
Oh, I'm free!
Freedom!
Oh, okay.
I have no idea where I am anymore.
I'm in somebody's room.
I hate this level.
I kinda like it.
I feel like while you guys are all stressing out, I'm being held like a baby.
I know!
It's pretty chill if you're not actually playing.
You get to be in the little hole.
Yes.
I feel like somebody on the other side just take us over.
It's just easier.
I'm holding several people.
Now I'm being held.
You don't have to spit people out yet.
I know.
And I'll start grabbing people.
Yeah, just grab people instead so we don't have to spit people out.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I think the other side doesn't have to spit people out.
The right side just grabs people over.
Yeah.
There we go.
See, it's that easy.
Okay, don't spit anybody out, guys, until we're at the other side.
Nobody has me!
Okay.
There was an attempt.
Yeah, one at a time.
Okay, go.
Okay, you guys are too close.
You can't suck.
I don't have anybody.
I don't have anybody to suck.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Put me back in.
Just be put in.
Let me put people in.
Let me do it.
Okay, nice, nice, but just keep putting people in your mouth.
Okay, I'm trying.
Just cram us in your mouth.
You got this.
Unlock the door.
Yeah, unlock the door.
Take your time.
It's me!
Fuck
that level.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Yay.
We're free.
No overtime limit.
Shoot them up, baby.
Oh.
This is memory right here.
Oh no.
We can shoot each other.
We can kill each other.
Blast my booty.
We're so fucked.
This is my area.
This is mine.
I'm at the very bottom.
Okay, make a path for us.
Make a path.
You have to shoot your own color.
Shoot your own color.
Learn colors.
Red, where's red?
Where's red?
I've done my part.
We need more than just two.
I was like, I've done my part and it's just two.
My job here is done.
Orange, orange, orange.
Make a long path.
Make a long path for us.
Get out of my way.
You're in front of me.
I did all of my colors.
I'm proud of you.
Me too.
Orange, orange, orange.
You guys were too cramped in.
I was too far behind.
I thought you did all your colors.
I did.
I'm gonna kill you right now.
I'm gonna kill you.
I swear to God.
You're just ehp Employee 3!
I knew you'd try a little harder.
I knew he'd mess up. coe solid I heard you shoot me in the back of the head and then drive full speed in.
Maybe.
Maybe?
I got more colors.
I got all blue!
Me, too.
we should do this right now look at that there's no more yellow
we line up in our colors and then just shoot in a line we won't shoot each other that's true yeah but then i think it's randomized It's randomized, isn't it?
I didn't know that.
It's randomized.
But as we see the color, we should...
We should...
As we see the color, we should line up possibly.
Oh, my God.
It's like kindergarten all over again.
All right.
Line up, guys.
Line up.
In a single file.
We need like a designated...
Green, yellow, blue, pink.
I need more.
I need more space.
Okay.
That's a lot of space.
I got mine.
It's not large enough.
I got my colors.
I'm at the very back.
Green, green, green.
I'm at the green.
The green, green, green.
The green.
Well...
Okay.
Yellow, yellow, yellow.
Green.
Green, green.
In the space.
Green, green, green.
Giants.
My ears.
My ears were stuck.
It was playing that little...
What do you mean?
Your ears were stuck.
I stood still.
Okay, it's over.
It's over.
It's just over.
It was a pixel.
We're okay everybody with the power of friendship.
We can do this.
Green and blue and then purple.
Up top because that's where the key is.
True, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I was just pressing up and I was not pressing space.
Why do they get smaller?
Oh, it's so small.
Okay, blue.
Okay.
Purple, purple, purple.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, single file, do not stop.
Don't stop.
Okay.
Alright, we're okay.
Where's the door?
Oh, there we go.
Where is the door?
What are you doing?
I'm like having you encircled four times.
Wait, I have to go in the bathroom.
Everyone call us.
I need one second.
Be right back.
Wait, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Alright, alright.
It's time out, time out.
Oh my god.
Hey guys.
This is a great game about friendship, isn't it?
I think we're learning a lot about each other.
Yeah, we're learning so much.
When are we doing competitive League of Legends?
Yes, please bro.
Wow, my PC is gonna crash at that exact moment.
How awkward.
What are we like boot camping here?
Like, surely this is just a training for something bigger, right?
Probably.
Yeah.
Monopoly.
Yeah, now that you're saying it.
Yeah, we're training for... what was it called?
The ninja thing?
Oh, American Ninja Warrior.
American Ninja, yeah!
Yeah, we're training for our own American Ninja.
Oh my god.
I watched that recently and the guy on there was like dressed as like his favorite Lord of the Rings character.
And he like tried to jump off the first thing and he...
He knows that!
He was like, I've been training in my favorite characters.
Like, who's the like sexy man from Lord of the Rings who like has a horse?
I've never seen him.
Oh, Eragor?
No.
Oh yeah, Eragor.
Legolas?
No, not Legolas.
He's the black guy.
Okay, sorry.
I'm just like really into Legolas, so...
Me as well.
Eragor, that's fair.
Eragor, he was like, Eragor is my soulmate.
He is my character.
He is just me depicted.
He's my kin.
He's my kin, Eragor.
So I'm going to slay him.
Parkour.
He just like missed the rope and like dipped it into the water.
And he had like chain mail and a coat and everything.
It was so good.
That's so sad.
That's devastating, yeah.
That poor guy.
Hey, at least he got his like 10 minute of fame there.
Is it even 10 minutes?
10 minutes.
No, it was like 30 seconds.
30 seconds of fame.
Yeah, but see, you remembered him though.
You remembered him.
He was the most impactful performer.
Yeah, you don't even remember the other people.
Like, who were the other guys?
You don't know.
Oh, no.
John Parkour.
What?
Okay, we're back.
All right, back to hell, I guess.
You're so back.
We're back to hell.
We go.
What?
It's the same thing.
We're on top of each other.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
There's no chutes.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm sorry.
The people on top of them.
They just go large for no reason.
The people on top of the plane.
If you're on top, don't move.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shit.
I swear to God.
Don't move.
Girl, I'm back.
No, I'm back.
Okay.
It's okay.
Ow.
Sorry.
What am I doing?
I just got back.
Okay.
Don't worry.
All right.
You and me, Mint.
Yeah.
There's no one on top of us.
Guys, I'm not good at Touhou.
I'm not good at Touhou.
My head.
Yes, please.
I can't beat Touhou.
Watch out for the ceiling.
Oh, okay.
I don't have to.
All right, Amelie.
Shoot.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I played Touhou.
Okay.
Don't shoot me.
I don't have a person.
All right, Lime.
Let's go.
Oh, what happened?
Amelie, why did you walk off?
If you get too close to the other ship, you can also knock off your little human.
Oh, thank God.
I'm just shooting.
I'm a cat.
Yeah.
We're kind of crazy.
Let's go, Snuffy.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Hello?
Joki actually just threw a ball at the back of my skull.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
Okay.
Bell.
Shoot Bell.
There we go.
All right.
Oh, great.
Great.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, no.
I think I just murdered Amelie.
I just murdered her.
In cold blood.
Oh, I don't have a person.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
My God.
Jennifer, I can catch you.
If you can't do Toho, then I can!
See, I dodged all of that!
It's not me!
Wait, I was bored without a person!
I was gonna jump on your head and trust your Toho!
We're all bored without a person, okay?
Okay, you're not stuck.
Oh no, oh no!
My head!
No!
Okay.
Alright, Amelie.
I'll get you through this, Amelie.
Shoot!
Shoot, Amelie!
I'm gonna dash you!
Violent!
She's got you!
Yeah!
That was so great!
No one heard me!
I didn't even move, I was clapping!
You all heard me!
I was literally like...
I was just clapping!
No one heard you!
We got this!
Yeah, we got this!
Just clap!
Nice, nice!
I know!
Shoot it!
There we go!
Very good!
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Yellow!
Doggy!
Oops!
I think I just, like, stole your person and then also, like, killed you.
And I was like...
That's okay!
I know!
I didn't do it!
I thought it was this ship.
That's my bad.
My person!
I was found without a person!
That pal?
No, I knocked somebody else's person.
Yeah, I have to steal somebody else's blood.
I'm gonna take a baby.
Do you have a USB?
We should start jumping from car to car.
I'm single and ready to mingle if anyone wants my car.
Uh-oh.
I have a...
A pretty Lamborghini.
Okay, okay.
Just keep spamming!
Just keep shooting!
I'm spamming!
Okay, where?
Alright, alright.
We're...
Oh!
No!
I'm sorry!
We lost two passages!
We lost two!
Oh my gosh!
What happened?
Not even nice.
Not nice.
There we go.
I don't feel comfortable at the tight passageway right there.
Nice and easy.
Guys, I'm all the way back here.
Guys, guys.
Boop me up!
I got pushed off!
I know.
Oh, thank god.
I don't have to deal with passports.
Somebody take...
How did that happen?
Take this!
I left this in my pocket.
Can you have it?
Nice!
Who's first?
Who needs to be first?
Where's my orange?
I got it!
Go get it!
So the person has to jump off.
Alright, Amelie.
You got this.
I'm driving.
Don't kill us.
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry, Doki.
I'm so sorry.
I was trying to dodge.
Put me into the laser!
I was entering a maze of maneuvers.
Okay, I trust you guys.
Okay.
Goodbye, live.
See you later, man.
I'm gonna kidnap this person.
I'm just shooting.
Anyway, I started blasting.
What if I just kidnap your person?
Go!
And then blue?
Yeah.
Oh!
Take it to the top!
Okay, whatever.
My bad.
What the hell?
I'm gonna put that on my soundboard.
My bad.
I'm a person.
Arms of an angel.
Where's this gonna land?
My head is almost gonna touch it.
There are things that are shooting us!
Get out of the way!
Pink!
Go!
Alright.
Oh god.
I'm so sorry.
Baby down!
We lost the baby!
Go to the intersection again.
Alright, Doki.
Oh, sorry.
What happened to Taro?
I don't know!
I'm so sorry.
It's not okay, Blue.
I have a dent.
We lost the train tracks!
Okay, we're okay.
Everything's okay.
We can do this.
My baby!
I'll get you!
We're okay.
This is the real time.
Okay.
Go, Pink!
Go!
Alright, Red in position.
Alright, Red!
Alright, go!
Red!
No!
I had no room.
I was just existing.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
It's just practice, guys.
It's just a trial run.
Okay, red.
And then orange.
Okay, and then we just keep going down.
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Yeah, see?
Look at that.
Not so difficult, guys.
Just like that.
Yeah, nice and easy.
Nice and easy.
Alright, who's first?
Blue!
Red, red, red.
Red, you need to just depart, go get it.
And then come back.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh my god, it's right there!
Look at that.
It wouldn't be a shame if I just moved up just one space.
Oh wait, how do we even do this?
Passengers get off first.
Passengers depart.
Yeah!
Yay!
That was actually so clean, though.
That was really clean.
So clean.
I didn't do anything.
That was kind of chill.
First try.
Oh wait, what's this?
Oh, I have power again!
Yeah!
We're really careful of shooting each other.
Oh, this is so zoomed in.
Oh!
Go, go, go!
Oh, weird, weird, weird, weird.
Gray, gray, gray, gray.
Uh oh.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's kind of fast, so it'll be okay.
Okay, let's go.
Gray?
Okay, I got the yellow.
I got the yellow.
Okay, we're figuring it out.
I'm gonna do a single file.
I feel like we should do a single file.
So we can just go up.
Pink and yellow.
We don't have to do both as long as like one section is clear.
Red and orange.
Or red.
You look like a rubber duck.
Oh yeah, we do.
Oh, I'm trying.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're doing it.
Orange and green.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, that was easy!
So easy!
Oh my god.
So easy.
Holy shit.
We don't have passengers.
Yeah.
We're just left with our own devices.
We're just not very good at partners.
Partner system.
We can't have a buddy.
Some people have shields.
Okay, block this.
I'll save you, my queen.
Get behind us.
Oh my god.
The music stopped.
What the fuck is that?
We need the shield.
Don't shoot the shield to the back.
Oh, be careful shield.
I can't.
I'm too scared to shoot.
I feel like I'm going to shoot somebody.
Just shoot!
Okay, oh, this is my...
Sorry, my bad.
You're so strong, Snuffy.
You're so strong.
Yeah!
Guys, I feel like...
Follow the shield!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I did not expect that.
We're so good at this.
Oh, oh, oh.
Don't worry, we have...
Yeah, yeah, just have them eat all the...
Yeah, eat it, eat it, eat it.
Eat it, eat it, eat it.
That's fucking right.
The ice shield!
We're so close!
We did so good.
Okay, that first try was pretty good.
Okay.
I'm already damaged.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
You can actually recover.
Yeah, eventually, yeah.
Okay, I'm just going to shoot from here.
Gamer, stay behind me.
Oh, don't shoot me, sorry.
Don't shoot me.
If you're staying behind the shield, don't shoot.
You're going to have to like...
You're going to have to move a little bit.
Gamer's got to be careful.
Gamer's got to learn trigger safety and discipline.
Oh shit, sorry, Gamer.
It feels like Pond right here.
No!
Okay, okay.
Stay behind, stay behind!
Get behind!
Get behind me!
Okay, Gamer, spread out.
Spread out, Gamer.
V formation, Gamer.
Oh, we're so close.
Oh my god, okay.
Guys, don't shoot the shields.
It's all we need to do.
V formation, V formation.
I'm focused, I'm focused.
Oh no!
Stand behind the shield if there's a missile.
Orange, you need to block the missiles.
No, they don't.
They just stay there.
Don't over complicate it.
Stop it, stop it, stop it!
We're fine, we're fine.
No, no, no, no.
V formation!
Watch out, Gamers!
What happened?
The missile got me.
The missile is one shot.
We were so close.
Alright, Gamers.
Be careful.
I'll eat as much as you can.
I'll eat as much as I can, Gamers.
I'll eat as much as I can.
I believe in you, man.
I believe in you.
You just flicked the back of my head last week.
I just like the color of your ship.
Because I gotta eat it!
I gotta eat it!
I'm sorry.
Get behind us, Gamers!
Get behind us!
Get behind!
Got you!
Did you shoot the shield guy?
Yeah, he deserved it.
Alright, we're gonna eat as much as we can.
Oh, this one shot, by the way, the missile is one shot!
Be careful, guys!
Be careful!
I learned it the hard way!
Eating as much as I can!
Here we go.
Oh, eat it, eat it!
It's delicious, eat it!
No!
Who killed me?
Oh, okay.
Because you're really good at it!
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
The game knows!
It won't let me play the game!
Alright, here we go.
Alright, Gamers, we're here!
They can't do anything to us!
Yeah!
Oh, ouch!
Too close!
We were too close.
This guy just, like, assassinated our shield.
Oh, there you go!
Back at it again!
Oh my god!
You're just really good at it!
The game knows!
Yeah, you're so good at tanking!
Okay, we have the system down.
Alright, Gamers.
We have...
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't be too close.
I don't think you guys have to move.
You guys can literally just...
stay there.
Yeah, yeah, like, we don't have to...
You don't have to...
Oh.
That's why we were moving a little bit.
But it's okay.
We stay like this.
We provide a safe zone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we can move from the others.
Okay, now we go back.
Alright, behind us, behind us.
This is one shot.
You die instantly.
Alright, nice.
We got this.
Halfway.
What is the lore of Pico Park?
We're at a park.
It's like...
It's like Chuck E.
Cheese, but like...
a little more dangerous.
Okay.
This is where I drop my kids off?
Yeah, this is where...
Yeah, this Pico Park...
We gotta head to the Pico Park.
Damn.
Are we gonna move for the missiles?
I think just a little bit is okay.
Be careful.
I got it.
Behind us, behind us, behind us.
Missile time, missile time.
The missile is getting very easy.
Our hero.
Okay.
Alright, gamers.
We got this.
I can't block that.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm trying.
I got him.
Missile time.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
I'll eat it, I'll eat it.
Oh, oh, oh.
So close, so close, so close.
Just gotta regen, regen.
I like how Amelie is just behind me.
Stop, stop shooting, stop shooting.
I'm so scared.
I just needed one more shot and I'd be dead.
Yay!
This is like the hardest part.
I know, right?
Oh my god, this is like a walk in the park.
Oh my god, I finished one area!
And one entire row!
Oh my god, look how close we are.
Look how close we are, guys.
We're just getting better.
Let's go to the shadow realm level.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Let's go to the shadow realm.
After this, we can use shadow realm.
What's this?
Don't hit it, don't hit it, I think.
It's too cute.
Wait, what are the people on the top?
I think it's the people that are moving are the ones up top.
Oh!
Oh, it's like a snitch.
Like who's...
Oh, because it's stop and go.
We have to go.
What?
Jump over it.
I thought he was going to keep going.
I don't know.
Maybe the person on the top can kill it?
I can't jump over it.
We need guns.
Let's just hop over it.
Wait, can we all move at the same time?
No, only four people can move.
Only four can...
Oh, we can jump on top!
Wait, did we go?
How come he's killed me like ten times?
The front four move.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Alright.
One at a time.
No, we could just have one person on top and then...
Now go.
Oh, it's only three at a time.
It's four.
Oh, it is four.
Alright.
Don't die to the laser.
I made a realization.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, dear.
Someone jump over me.
Can you just jump straight down to get the key?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice.
Oh, but it is a treadmill.
Okay, I'll go.
Oh.
Let's just go at the far end and then let go.
Okay, we have four people moving now, so be careful.
Okay.
I do not know where...
Oh, shoot.
Hold on.
There we go.
Oh, it is a treadmill.
This went down two or two.
Oh, my God.
You just gonna have to coordinate it so we're all moving.
Oh, God.
Okay.
This is fine.
We got this.
Can we push people?
No.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
We already got one person out of the treadmill.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
I'm just gonna stop.
They just have to not move.
Okay, okay.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah.
Oh, and then that's good.
We got four.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Oh,
my God.
Easy.
So easy.
And then we push it.
Push, push, push, push.
Okay, I have the key.
Nice.
Now jump up.
Oh, yeah.
Fucking easiest level.
Nice.
Yay.
Oh, my God.
You know what?
That was so easy.
We might as well do the dark level.
Which one is it?
Is it...
Is this?
That one?
It looks like...
Special Park?
That's us.
We're Special Park.
That would be us.
Is that it?
We actually did, like, one of the levels in Special Park.
Wait.
Oh, that's the one with the button!
Remember when Min...
This is fucking cursed, man.
What is this?
What does that mean?
So, wait.
White, orange, and blue?
Are those us?
Are those other players?
Oh, I'm blue!
I'm blue!
Okay, so we need...
I'm blue.
We need six people to do blue.
What does this even mean?
It's right and left.
Oh!
Okay, I can do orange.
Yeah.
So, it's depending if you go left or right.
Oh, so, like, left, middle, right?
We have to map it to the left.
Oh, the animation they're doing.
Okay.
What the...
How the hell do we do this?
So, Bow, I think you can turn to the right and jump.
So, I'm moving left.
I'm moving left.
We need two more people moving left.
I'm doing it.
How do we get grey?
We just face left side.
Because if you jump, you float.
Ah, I see.
We need one more person moving left.
We need one more person moving left and then jumping.
I think all of... wait.
Only six people need to be jumping.
Whoever is orange...
I moved left and jumped.
You can jump and move left at the same time.
Yeah, yeah.
Jump and move left at the same time.
We need one more person doing whatever orange is doing.
What the fuck is orange doing?
Just moving right.
Oh, okay.
Somebody move grey!
We were so close.
We almost figured it out.
My brain.
Okay, I'm going to move left.
I moved left too.
I went right.
I'm orange.
I'm doing orange.
We need somebody to move left.
Oh!
Too many orange.
Alright, wait.
Okay, we need somebody to jump.
Somebody...
We need two more people to jump.
Green, can you jump?
Yeah, I guess.
Hold on.
There we go.
And we need an orange.
And we need a grey.
We need one more orange.
Um...
Oh my god.
Are we missing somebody?
Somebody is not...
Somebody... Okay.
One more person on orange.
So you need to be right.
Like going right.
You can jump and move a direction at the same time.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's several!
Okay, everybody look to the left.
And one person jump.
And that's it.
What the fuck is this?
Help.
Oh, there we go.
Everybody look to the right.
Nobody jump.
Don't jump.
Everybody just look to the right.
Okay.
Oh, that was so close.
Oh, there we go.
Why is there more?
I'm crying.
We got stuck on the first one for so long.
We get it now.
This is special.
Okay, I'm moving to the right and I'm jumping.
We need one more.
Oh, and I'm jumping.
We need one more right to move to the right.
Okay, nice.
I'm moving to the right and I'm...
I'm moving to the left.
We need one person to move to the right.
One more to the left.
One just left.
I'm going just left.
Who's not doing it?
Who's not moving at all?
I'm moving to the right.
I'm moving to the left.
We need somebody to jump.
Okay, I jump.
We need one more person to jump.
One more person to jump.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, the pie chart.
Okay, I'm jumping.
I'm on the right.
Perfect.
Nailed it.
I'm right jumping.
I'm jumping right.
Oh, nice.
Four more.
Okay, everybody to the left.
Everybody to the right.
Right side.
Pie chart time.
Oh, wait.
No jumping.
Okay, one person.
Only one person needs to do it.
Only one person.
One person needs to do it.
No, actually not one.
Oh, no, no, no.
Stop jumping.
Who's jumping?
Criss-cross now.
Slide to the left.
We're so close.
Nice.
Okay, jump.
No going to the right.
There we go.
Okay.
Now, only going to the right and jumping.
Okay, who's going to the left?
Who's got it?
There we go.
We did it.
I will go left.
We need one more right.
Gosh, they're really just kind of...
Okay, nice.
I feel like that one's easier to juke.
Nice, nice.
I'm on right side.
No jumping.
Go to the back.
Jumping back.
Left, left, left.
We need one more left.
Okay.
Alright.
One person goes to the left.
We did it.
We're figuring stuff out.
Nice, nice, nice.
Everybody jump.
I'm jumping right.
We need one more right.
One more left.
It's still timed.
Go, go, go, go.
Jesus Christ.
I think Dark Park...
My brain hurts.
I think Dark Park only exists.
I told you a little jumping slice appeared and I would look down about.
It was just one jump.
Oh, this is fun.
Pinball.
We're playing pinball.
This is going to be fun.
Bow.
That wasn't me.
It's fine.
We can coordinate this.
This is all on your own.
No teamwork needed is reflexes.
Yeah, no teamwork needed.
No to blame.
You miss your individually bad at the game.
Yay!
Gamers, gamers.
Gamers.
At least we proved to everybody that we're gamers.
Yeah, we're good at this.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You guys, that was my brain cell rattling around my skull.
Gamers confirmed.
That's a lot of dudes.
Wait, what do you fucking mean?
Oh, no.
I know who I am.
I know.
I found me.
I know who I am.
I got me.
I found me.
Okay.
I don't know.
Where am I?
Oh, oh.
Oh, the turns!
Wait, what?
Turns?
No, I think you're supposed to...
Oh, I just picked the wrong one because I thought it was like...
I found you.
We all have to fight each other.
I picked the one above me.
Okay, I found me.
I found me.
I found who I am.
Oh, no.
I thought I found me, but I think I was wrong.
No.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we can do this, guys.
I found me.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, me too.
I found me.
I found me too.
Alright, I stopped moving when I found myself.
Just stop moving when you find yourself.
Okay.
I need to go on a journey of self-discovery.
I'm finding myself.
Oh, we did it.
We found ourselves.
I found myself.
You are an individual.
We're all special, guys.
Alright, back to stop and go.
Wait, I think we are...
Oh.
Oh, it's red light, green light.
Okay, guys.
We got to not move.
Wait for him to turn around.
Okay, guys.
We got to not move.
I think he's red.
Turn around.
If he goes red, you stop, I think.
I don't think he's going to go...
I think this one person nudges very slowly.
Maybe we don't look at him?
Oh, no.
That's like bad aim.
I say that.
Alright.
I think it's just one person at a time.
Can we look?
Can we conga line?
Oh, it might be one person.
Oh, hey guys.
I win.
Maybe it's a one person thing.
Yeah.
Okay, so just the person in the front.
No!
Donkey!
I thought I was in the front.
Technically, I'm in the front.
Out of all the game modes, this is going to be...
I'm always going to be...
It's okay.
Just go.
Okay, now Amelie goes.
Now I'm going to go.
Okay.
It would be funny if I just move right now.
I'm stopping now.
I'm going.
Red rover!
Send mint over.
Joopy!
Alright.
Donkey.
Wait, he might turn around, so be careful.
I'm going to unlock the door.
I don't want to go one at a time.
Yeah, I think so too.
This is like teaching manners, honestly.
Wait for your turn.
Yeah!
Kind of hard.
We did it!
We're starting in a kindergarten now.
Good job, class.
It's harder than it looks, you guys.
Single file line.
We're going to the bathrooms.
Okay, what's this?
Oh boy.
Oh.
Wait, isn't this the one level we have to avoid?
We shouldn't do, right?
We can only move when the light turns out.
Or when it turns all white.
Or am I like fading in and out of consciousness?
No, you're right.
It is restarting.
Oh yeah, you can only move when it's on.
Wait, isn't this the level that people tell us not to do?
Oh, this might be the level that flashes.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think we should do this one.
Okay, we can skip it.
Wait, it says we can finish game.
Does it pass it?
Does it automatically finish it for us?
Wait, I want to see.
It says we can finish game.
But I don't know if it automatically...
finish end game.
Let's just go.
Oh!
You can't!
I thought it would finish it for us!
Yo, Will!
Are you kidding me?
Sorry, I'll make a new one.
That's why I'm bad at games.
That's why I'm bad.
I think I get it now.
Now that I know what finish...
I thought it would actually...
It would make us let us finish the level.
And I'll be like, whoa, that's cool.
Game finished.
Alright, I put the new code in.
Don't leak the code.
No leakers.
Are we dodging that level?
Is it giving people headaches?
Yeah, I think we should dodge it.
It's probably not good for people watching.
Yeah.
It's sort of like, not exactly like fast flashing.
But it's definitely disorientating.
It's not for our sakes.
It's for the viewers.
We're worried about you guys.
We're so worried about you guys.
I only care about chat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
2, 4...
Guys, stop, stop.
2, 4... Okay, we're missing one.
There you go.
Please, I can't count.
You know, there is a counter in the corner.
It says, 7 out of 7.
Never trust technology.
Okay, go get the apples.
I've got apples.
Oh, f%%&n, hell.
I've got an apple.
Shut this one.
We have to make sure everybody has an apple.
Guys, we can't just give it to Mip.
Everybody needs to have an apple.
Sorry, I'm just so good at catching them.
Apple.
Give me the apple.
Wait, how many apples?
I'm really good at catching these apples 34.
Oh, we got 13.
Keep catching, keep catching.
I'm catching apples.
I'm trying!
Ten!
Apple.
Oh.
Okay, maybe shoot them when we're close by.
Alright.
Four more!
They go really far.
Apple.
Okay.
Two to two.
I'm shot one.
Okay.
Go go go!
Nice.
Okay.
First try, baby!
We're doing so good!
We're like first try.
I know!
We are gamers!
We're better than flesh and blood.
We're really fine.
What's this?
Yay!
More balls!
What do you do here?
I don't know.
We catch it and then we shoot it.
We're gonna shoot it.
We're gonna shoot it in the basket.
It's like basketball.
We're gonna basketball this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Here we go.
Oh god.
I got one.
This is actually convoluting.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, if you drop it, you lose it.
I formally request you get off my head.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
I just stole that.
How do I get it in?
What the freak?
No!
You set the angle, then you set the power.
Oh, I don't like this.
Yeah.
Oh, people can get in the way of your balls.
Oh!
I hate this one.
This one sucks.
You guys can, like, smack them out of other people's head.
Guys, we gotta work together, guys.
We gotta...
Oh, come on.
We got...
Oh my god!
That thing's...
We're smacking it!
I haven't gotten a single ball.
I got two in.
I'm doing my part.
I haven't gotten a single ball.
I'm actually gonna throw up.
I can't do this anymore.
I'm doing my part.
Oh, look at that.
I got all of it.
I love this game.
It feels like we're playing those arcade basketball games.
Yeah.
I hate these.
No!
You ain't trying.
Collecting balls.
I'm collecting balls.
Oh, wait.
I got one.
Spare balls?
I got one, too!
Wait, I'm crazy.
Oh my god.
No.
Oh god.
Oh, son of a...
Shit.
Oh, fuck.
I saw that.
No!
You were gonna steal it from me.
It's either mine or yours.
Come on.
I got a ball.
I have four balls.
Anybody need some balls?
I got a ball!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh, please.
Oh, god.
Oh, I have one.
Oh, we're so bad.
I swear to fuck this is not consistent.
How many do I need?
Oh my god.
I got one.
One more.
Last two.
Come on.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Guys.
We lose.
It's literally two.
Literally two.
Guys.
It's so hard.
Are you serious?
No!
Oh my god.
I think we all moved the slide and we left the game or game.
I just shoved six balls into my mouth.
I have the mouth of a squirrel.
What the hell did you just say?
This has been my area this whole time.
You guys get out.
I've been...
I've been managing.
No!
Where's the bead?
Oh my god.
Guys.
Guys, we're a team, guys.
Let me have some balls.
This is for the girl you need done.
This is for an unbelievably even...
I'm just going to crack it out.
...some wide br .
Shoot them.
Guys, there's so...
Why are you rocking all the fucking balls?
Please, guys!
I'm so tired of life.
Please, guys.
Oh my god.
Why was I fuckcking off, bro?
Please, guys.
Let me have some balls.
You have to make it if you get all the balls!
You have to be able to make it!
You can't have all the balls for yourself, that's all it takes!
I was like, I'm tired, I'm trying, I wanna fuck around too.
Get away from me, get away from me, get away from me, get away from me!
Alright, there we go guys, I will get in between you two!
Oh, I made it, I made it!
Guys, nope, I am the couples counselor, guys, get away, get away from each other, get away!
Hey, hey, hey, I'm making my hits, okay?
Alright, we did it, we did it!
I'm trying this time, I promise!
Oh, we did it, we did it!
Yay!
Alright, one of us will get to...
Oh shoot!
Guys, please, please, I can't, guys, please, I need that, guys, no!
Oh, oopsie!
Yay!
Oh my god, last three!
Oh no!
Ah!
One of my hits!
One of my hits, okay!
I think my ball is lined up!
I had it lined up!
No!
Oh shoot!
One of us!
No!
Why did you drag your body through this door like a wild animal?
Why!
Why were you at the corner!
Why were you just there!
I was in my own world!
That area was done!
That's insane!
It was the first one to be finished too!
Oh!
I was...
I...
I wasn't all here, I swear!
Oh, I can tell!
You know what, I'm gonna stay right by the door!
No, no, that was the issue!
We got it, we got it, we got it!
Go, go, go!
That looks like a bomb!
Get in!
Grab me by the fucking throat!
That looks like a bomb!
Hi guys, I'm here, I'm here.
No, I'm not here.
Hey, what's up?
Back, back at it again!
We gotta collect this time, there's more apples!
Don't, don't, don't!
Don't shoot the bomb!
Please!
Someone grab this?
Don't shoot the bomb!
What the hell is going on, bro?
Guys, I want an apple too!
No, no, no bomb, no bomb, no bomb!
Bomb trick!
Oh nice, okay, I got one.
La bomb.
I can't tell if it's a bomb anymore.
I'm scared of the bomb.
You can't tell what is red and what is black!
Sometimes they change!
They are changing.
Oh shoot.
Oh!
It's fine, 8 more, 8 more in 12 seconds!
We can do this!
Stop shooting the ones that are far away!
I'm dorky!
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it, guys.
We're gonna make it, we're gonna make it!
Come on, shoot her!
We got this, we got this!
Wait, how do you control?
How do you shoot?
You have a cool down though, you have a cool down.
Oh, okay, okay.
I got this area covered.
Oh Jesus!
Don't shoot the bomb!
I think the bomb makes it so that all our apples disappear!
I don't know though, I'm just making things up.
You shoot the bomb, you have 5 minutes left to live.
Send this forward to 10 other people.
Oh no, we got a bomb.
Alright, nice.
Dude, unlock the fucking...
We're so locked in.
Give me these things.
Apple.
Oh no.
My brain's turned into such fucking mush that all I can do is...
Okay, we have 10 seconds, we have 10 seconds.
Apple.
Okay, go, go, go.
No!
I couldn't!
People were blocking my way!
That sucks!
Oh...
It's okay, we did it.
We got in.
Oh no!
Oh my god, there's bombs!
Noooo!
I hate this one!
We live here now.
This is where we live now.
This is okay, we're getting better, we're getting better at copying.
Are we?
We haven't got a single one, but we're getting better, guys.
I got one!
Oh, thanks for doing it.
I like your corner over here, it's nice.
Us two, us two here.
Hey, hey.
Hey now.
Let's play nice.
Let's play nice live.
Last one, last one!
Sorry, I can't shoot.
We're leading one!
I got this, I believe!
I got it, I got it, I got it!
No, shvuck!
No!
We're leading one!
Oh, guys.
Oh dear.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Wait, what?
I guess.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Run!
Oh, my.
I love when we win and nobody's expecting it.
So we just start shaking each other up.
Yeah.
Swapping in person to person so fucking easily.
It's awful.
It really does.
It's exactly like a crowd panic.
It's so horrifying.
We're like, please!
Stay calm, everybody!
And everybody just runs around.
Please, women and elderly first!
And I push the elderly down.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, no, no!
I messed up.
Oh, no.
It looks like if you actually hit it on the downswing, there's like no power whatsoever.
So you have to go back up again.
They're different.
I genuinely haven't gotten like a single ball.
I don't know where I am.
I'm just gonna see if I make it.
Oh, you're good.
You don't die, though.
You don't die.
Yeah, you don't die.
You just get immobilized.
I believe in you, Amelie.
I swear these are different.
I believe in you.
I'm gonna watch until you get it in.
I fucked up.
Oh, guys.
Guys.
Guys, it's right behind us.
Go, go, go!
We literally need like one or two more seconds.
We got it this time, for sure.
We figured it out.
Wait, there's numbers on the top of the basket?
Are you actually serious?
No, there's no way.
Are you lying?
There's no way.
Amelie, this is your second time playing.
Amelie, you cannot be serious.
You cannot be serious, Amelie.
Amelie, do you wear glasses?
You're watching me.
I'm actually gonna cry.
There's no way.
I can't.
She's lying, chat.
Guys, guys, she's lying.
She's just making content, guys.
There's no way.
She's farming clips right now.
She's just farming.
She's farming clips for her TikTok, guys.
There's no way.
Just one more.
One of us will get it in.
Come on, guys.
Gamers.
Guys, we need Lillian.
Guys.
I can't get this.
What is happening?
Yeah.
We are so bad at this.
Just stay quiet.
Did nobody go to Chuck E.
Cheese as a kid?
Come on.
It's showing.
Chuck E.
Cheese doesn't exist here.
Okay.
I wasn't here.
My bad.
Yeah, but now you can go to Chuck E.
Cheese now, Amelie.
You can go there now.
Oh, my God.
That'd be such a funny video.
Val, can I help you?
Val?
No, sorry.
We got the right side done.
Sorry.
I think I'm getting better at this.
Yeah.
I really got the feel for it now.
Okay.
I missed two after I said that.
I got it.
I wanted to stay.
I'd like to stay the same.
I do okay right up until there's lots of people here.
And I can't get my perfect angle that I just do over and over again.
Oh, yeah.
That perfect.
Because everybody's watching and there's so much pressure.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
It's just you're in the fucking way.
God damn it.
Whoa.
That was off the rim.
That should have been in.
All right.
I did my job.
I'm just going to wait here.
Because I don't think we're going to make it, guys.
Yes, we are.
Oh, no, we're not.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
It could be a miracle.
What's that dog on the...
The dog on the basketball.
Air Bud.
Guys, I don't think we're him.
The dog on the basketball.
Don't stand on my head.
I need to shoot out.
A miracle will happen.
The dog will come.
The air Bud will show up.
The fucking basketball messiah, Air Bud.
Air Bud just falls from the sky.
He's the secret.
Oh, shit.
If you say Air Bud three times in the mirror, he'll show up.
Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud, Air Bud.
Oh, my God.
I feel him.
His spirit is inside of me.
Okay.
He didn't understand how this game worked.
Okay, Middle.
Middle.
The last three.
The last one.
He just kicked my ball out of my hand.
Yes.
LElere goes one more.
Two more.
Me too.
Oh, come on, we're so close!
Be with me!
Airpods!
Get in, get in, get in!
Oh, I redeemed myself with that one, let me tell you.
Oh, my Airpods, let's go Airpods!
Show me Airpods!
See, it happened as soon as you started saying Airpods.
Top down view, what the fuck is this?
Oh, we have to be in the light?
Oh, it's Metal Gear!
Oh, we each have to...
Oh, we can't go through the holes!
The holes.
Don't touch the black thing.
Yeah, I think we each have to step on a button.
I got this side.
It's clearly the pit!
That's a pit.
It's clearly a pit?
Why would that be clearly a pit?
Just don't fall, dummy!
What do you mean?
I'm getting smaller!
Well, it wasn't only after I died, I realized that.
Everybody grab a button.
Grab a button.
Nice!
Guys, I'm falling!
I'm falling!
Stop falling!
You have two legs!
I'm sorry!
I wear a size 12.
My shoes are so big.
Yeah!
I absolutely...
She wears a clown suit.
Just look at your little shadow on your feet!
My Kingdom Hearts shoes had my...
My weakness.
Okay.
Careful with your shoes, Nuffy!
Careful!
I'm going very slow!
Watch out for me.
Yeah.
And then one more here.
Oh!
We have to bait the...
Okay, I guess we fucked.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
And then we bait the bat.
Bait the bat.
Okay, so everybody but one person get on their buttons.
And then one person has to do the timing.
How do I bait it?
Oh God, I'm scared.
Okay, I'll get off the button.
I'll get it off.
Okay.
Okay, I...
You do it.
Oh, my button!
You have to bait it towards...
Why did you go down?
It's like it's a 50-50 and you jump down.
It's just a damn bat.
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Somebody else is wearing the clown shoes.
Valerie 3 was so loud, I'm scared for heaven.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah, okay.
We got this guys.
I believe in us.
I'm gonna be normal now.
All right.
Oh, Steffi, I saw that.
No, no, no.
Don't look at me.
No.
That was clean.
Go ahead.
I will bait the bat.
Oh, you will do it?
Okay.
You do hit the button.
I believe in you.
All right.
Ready, ready, ready.
Okay, we're ready.
I'm gonna fuck up.
Maybe.
Oh, drop it.
Oh.
She fucked up.
There's a delay.
Yeah.
That was good though.
Good timing.
Yeah, but we figured out the timing.
We figured it out.
Just get a right score who steps into the.
Oh, clown shoes.
The word this time will be different, guys.
Right there.
So, you have to wait for it to move a little bit, but not too much because there is a fucking delay on it.
Nice.
I believe in us.
I believe in us, Kriu.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I'm so sorry, Steffi.
It's okay.
I've mastered it.
No.
This is not fun.
Alright.
Okay.
Take it easy now.
You guys got it.
I'll do it.
I trust you.
That's ill-advised.
She has the most experience.
Yeah, exactly.
You almost ran off.
That was crazy.
It looks like the Nightbot.
Let Juniper go first.
Wait, wait, wait.
Grab the key from her.
Alright.
No, no.
You guys go.
You go.
The whole point was the key should not be in Amelie's head.
It's like fighting at its last moment.
Okay, you go.
Go, go, go.
We figured it out.
We figured it out, guys.
Oh, my God.
That was so scary.
How do I go in?
You put the keys in my hand.
No, Amelie can't go in.
Alright.
Another top-down view.
Oh, God.
Guys, we figured it out.
Oh, what?
Oh, no.
We have to catch them.
How?
We need to sort it out.
There we go.
Like that.
Oh, it's dying.
It's dying.
Kill it.
We don't want him to breathe.
Oh, this is time, guys.
This is time.
We gotta catch more.
Catch more.
Kill him.
Don't let him breathe.
We don't have air holes in here.
Just remember, we have no air holes.
Oh, I see.
Just being near us, it's like we're emitting a stink.
There must be...
Guys, we're on stream.
We're on stream.
Oh, no.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
We're gonna die.
That was so close.
Never cross the stream.
Okay.
I am...
We have to go down.
Come snuggle with me, Snuffy.
We'll be great.
Get that one right there.
Get two.
Double kill.
Oh, my God.
Triple kill.
Nice.
Oh, there's the door.
There's the door.
Good to know.
We were so fucking doomed last time because we had no idea what the door was.
Two more.
Yeah.
We're at the bottom.
Do we have to navigate over there?
It's our big rope creation, too.
No, I think we just need to kill the butterflies and then...
It's a free-for-all.
Yeah.
And then we go straight top right.
Alright.
Nice.
Grab.
Go.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
That was so easy.
We're such a good team.
Yeah.
That was faster.
Almost.
But we still made it.
Oh, okay.
Who can hide?
Wait, what does it mean to hide?
Who's hiding?
Who can hide?
Who's hiding right now?
Can anybody?
Can anybody hide?
Oh, you can.
Oh.
I made them.
Oh, wait.
Metal Gear Man.
That's a Metal Gear reference.
Yeah, that's a Metal Gear reference.
Oh, it's me.
It's me.
Get out.
I wanna be the one.
Okay.
I'm gonna keep dying until I get the box.
It's me.
Okay.
Let's go.
It won't let you use the box if they...
I think once you're caught.
Yeah.
Okay.
Who has it?
Oh, it's me.
It's me.
I think it's whoever's in the far top.
Oh.
Ooh.
Goodbye.
I think if you ran to the box, you'll be safe.
Yeah.
Okay.
Who has it?
It's me.
All right.
We gotta let Mint go first.
Go.
Nice.
We're so safe.
Okay.
Go.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Those ones are so suspicious.
They tricked you.
They went out of sync.
Those on the right were so suspicious.
They were like, that was weird.
All right, Emily.
Let her go first.
You got this.
All right.
Nice.
They're out of sync now.
They get suspicious.
They like, kind of be like, oh, I see that box.
Yeah.
Who has it?
It's me.
We have to learn the stealth.
Okay.
Wait.
Next time.
Go.
Get inside.
Sorry.
I thought I was in.
He stood in front of the box.
Oh, I have it.
I have it.
All right, guys.
I'm known for my stealth.
We know.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
We're still here.
They do go back into sync.
Nice.
Go.
Okay.
Nice.
No problem.
Hold on.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to...
Wait.
Box.
Oh, fuck.
What do you mean, box, folks?
You just ran up there.
That wasn't me.
I wouldn't run up there.
Hey, Jennifer.
You know what I mean?
Me?
Oh, it is me.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yippee.
All right, everybody.
I don't know.
Oh.
I ain't waiting.
You gotta say when.
I'm waiting for Stuffy.
I made it.
Okay.
Ready?
This one.
Go.
Uh-oh.
All right.
We just wait until they both turn up.
Okay.
Wait.
What happened?
Okay.
One day it will be my turn to wield the box.
I believe.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
That was my first box.
I did not know.
Who has it?
It's me.
No.
I didn't even get to use it.
Okay.
This is my redemption arc.
I believe in you, Stuffy.
Get nice and close to the line.
Okay.
Wait.
Wait after this.
Okay.
I'm going.
Please get up.
All right.
Let's go.
Uh-oh.
We are waiting for you.
Yeah, wait.
Everybody in the boat.
Alright, they're tricking you.
I got stuck in the boat!
Who has it?
I think it's me again.
Okay.
Alright, everyone gather.
Okay, we go.
Oh, we're good?
Nice.
Wait for it.
Wait for the second.
Alright, we go.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
We let them sink, okay?
We go.
Okay, and then we wait.
Then we wait.
We're gonna turn around.
When they turn around, I'm gonna go up.
Wait, can we touch them?
Or...
I don't think...
I don't...
Yeah.
Follow, follow, follow.
Okay, follow, follow, follow.
The cake.
Oh, no!
No!
Cake, cake, cake, cake, cake.
What the fuck?
Oh, no, no, no!
I...
What is it?
Emily has it.
Oh, how do you know?
Oh, at the top.
Because it's the top...
Top left person has it.
Ready after this one?
Box.
Oh.
Oh...
Box time.
We're so close to the edge.
This is sort of scary.
Yeah, it is scary.
She's so paranoid.
Two steps box.
Here we go.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice box.
Nice, okay.
Oh, they can hit you.
So you can't unbox it in time.
No way.
What the hell?
It's risky because you can't see exactly how far people are spread out under the box.
So there might be some tailenders.
Who has it?
Oh god, I'm not good at this.
Oh no.
You're gonna be great.
It's okay.
You can jump off the ledge if you don't want to do it.
You're good.
You can jump off the ledge.
I think that's the most like, pussy way out ever.
Don't worry, I can do it for you.
I can't move.
I can't go forward.
You guys are literally pointing a wall.
All you need to do is lock in.
Fill the wall router.
Okay.
Nice, clean.
No, go.
No, no, no, no, no.
Patience.
Okay, after this one.
Oh, okay.
Patience.
Okay.
After this.
All right, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, nice.
Slow and steady.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then we can go up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Are we going up?
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, no.
I think it's a little confusing because if people walk forward without me, then I get scared.
But I can't go ahead because it's like body blocking.
Yeah.
No, me again?
No.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
This is your training arc.
Oh, yeah.
It was just a training arc.
This is your training arc.
So I was like, all right, that's the sign.
Oh, I know.
I know.
Okay.
Okay, who's next?
Oh, okay.
Give me the box.
This is nonsense.
It's me.
This is me.
Page.
Page is like no.
Not Amelie.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, girl.
Please!
No.
Not Amelie.
We're trapped!
Okay.
Okay, all right.
Let's go after this one.
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh, no.
We're fine.
Hang on, hang on.
Wait for them to sing.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm going to go.
I'm going to go.
I'm boxing.
Boxing.
Okay, this one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure, for sure.
Alright, we're good.
Nice.
Oh!
Okay, sure.
Okay.
It's okay, you're fine.
Okay, not trust.
You could've gone!
Oh, that's a shadow.
Oh, I'm crazy.
I'm actually crazy.
Fuck!
Alright, go now.
Go now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, box, box, box.
Wait for them to pass us.
Wait for them.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go.
We can just box.
That's fine too.
Okay, it's fine.
Nice.
Do not fall into the pit.
Listen to me.
Guys, guys.
Don't fall in.
Okay.
Mint, if you really wanna be Metal Gear, you can do something funny.
I was gonna say.
If you really wanna do it.
I really wanted to be in the box again.
It's my destiny to be in the box.
We might have another level with bombs.
I said this was Metal Gear earlier and everyone made fun of me.
Alright, Mint, you know.
No, I'm just saying.
You should do it.
Don't be so funny.
I'm just saying.
The darkness.
Don't you wanna do the box?
Don't you?
I can't hear you.
Do it.
The green goblin.
Jump.
Don't be a pussy.
Oh my god.
Don't do it.
There's so much.
Toki.
How do I get out of the room?
Get off the ledge, Toki.
Don't tell her how to get out of the room.
I made it.
Mint, you wanna do the box, right?
Do it.
It's not a job.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta make sure Mint gets there.
No, wait.
No, actually.
No.
It's okay.
No, Toki.
You can't have this privilege.
Oh my god.
I want Lime to have the box.
I can't fucking take it anymore.
We'll do a level where Lime takes us to the end and then we'll do a level where Pink takes us to the end.
Oh my god.
Can we do another level with all of our hands?
Your present to me for me not having the box is just to let the level end.
Please.
Let me go fuck out.
No, we already committed.
Oh my god.
Do you realize how many times it took for me to get the box?
We won.
We'll never get it.
It's fine.
Just go.
I redeemed myself and you guys are going away.
No, okay.
I like how they're like, no, Mint and Lime should have the box.
And Mint and Lime are like, please, no.
Just fuck off.
We'll keep going.
It will work.
It's either Mint or Lime will get it.
Why is it always me?
Why is it always you?
I think because you keep dying.
Alright, then Mint, you jump off.
Yeah, yeah, you jump off.
Okay, for science.
Yeah, for science.
He's like, what?
Yay.
We're trapped here.
We're not It's not because we're dumb.
We have the box.
Alright, I'm taking a peek.
Oh, no.
Please, lead us to victory.
I want to escape.
This is it.
Let me out.
I don't have the fight in me.
You guys have to role play with me, okay?
Okay.
Okay, what are we role-playing?
Wait, we have to wait for Amelie to come back.
What about you?
Lime, do you want the box?
We don't want the box anymore.
Just put the box on top of her.
Just go down and put the box on top of her.
I won't take her with us.
Yeah, I can't move with the box.
Fake Metal Gear.
Yeah, but we start the role-play now.
Oh, okay.
Build a scene.
Let's do some world building.
Yeah.
Okay, what's the scene?
With the bat.
Okay.
How do we get here?
What are we trying to steal?
We're trying to destroy Metal Gear.
Oh.
My name is... I'm Placid Snake.
So Jumble has done it again.
Placid Snake.
Placid.
Yeah, I'm Placid Snake.
Okay.
Alright, I'll be Plastic Snake.
Plastic Snake.
Plastic Snake, that's good.
Yeah.
Okay, who else?
I'm Dysfunctional Snake.
We can have as many snakes.
Dysfunctional Snake.
They sound like Toontown auto-generated names.
That's so real.
I'm Sniffer Snake.
I'm Sleepy Snake.
Someone has to be Jurassic Snake.
Jurassic Snake?
I'll be Jurassic Snake.
Yeah.
Yeah, you are.
I can't remember what anyone...
Alright, I'm back.
Have we...
Alright, now we're role-playing.
We just got Mint the Box.
Incredible.
Now we must...
What's your snake name, Amelie?
What's your snake name?
Blasted Snake.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
I thought you said Plastered Snake.
That's a good one, too, actually.
No, that's you, Snuffy.
Everyone can get in.
We're all good.
Alright, after this next one, after this next one, I'm moving.
You got that?
Alright.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah.
Let him sink.
Somebody give us BGM from Metal Gear.
Duh-duh.
Duh-duh-duh.
Go, go, go.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, get in the box!
Get in the box!
I was going to say, after all we've done.
Okay, okay, okay.
Who just sentenced us into the pit for 5000 years?
Okay.
Get in the box!
Run, run, run!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Get in the box!
Okay, your okay.
Your okay.
Get in the box!
Oh, my god.
Okay, just get out of the way.
Just- Lime is on the edge.
You can wave!
Lime is living on the edge.
Lime was like, watch this though.
Okay guys, everybody single file Lime and get into the door.
I will scream so hard that Sonic will explode.
All I'm saying is that Lime didn't have a chance to be Metal Gear.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm going to mail you my head in a box.
It's too fat to fit through the...
How are you going to send it in the mail if you're already...
Thanks for letting me be John Metal Gear.
You're welcome.
Now happy to do it.
We did it guys.
We did it.
Oh no.
We have to...
Everyone go down your own little path.
We all have our own path in life.
This is my path.
Find your path.
This is my hole.
It was made for me.
Okay, everybody be careful on your path.
I feel like it's the corner.
You guys, there is a fan up there.
We've got to sink the corners.
Guys please, this is supposed to fit me in this hole.
Get to the corner and then pause.
Just pause.
And then...
Oh no.
I think you've got to get over.
Someone's pulling, right?
It's not going to be everybody's pulling.
Yeah, we're all pulling.
We're all connected.
It could have been everybody.
It could be any one of us.
It could be you.
It could be me.
Pause, pause.
Go left and pause.
Who didn't pause?
I paused.
I tried to pause.
Alright.
Everybody pause.
Then go to the other corner and pause.
Okay, pause.
We're all going to go together.
Now we're going to go down this.
I think we should just run for it.
Run, run, run.
I heard run.
We were doing so good.
We were doing so literally flawless.
And we were like...
It's the fence.
We've got to go past the fence.
Run.
We went from precision to this.
Every people for themselves.
It's the fence.
We can't get caught by the doki doki.
I'm not pulling.
What do you want from me?
First corner.
Go straight and pause.
Everybody pause.
I'm watching all of you.
Okay, left.
Okay, now pause.
Now we're going to go up.
Now we're going to go to the left and then pause.
And then walk the catwalk.
What do we do about bow and the fence?
No!
Doki!
What do you mean?
Bow dropped two at the same time.
All three of us died.
Bow was fighting a fan.
You have no excuse.
I have no excuse.
You're laughing.
Corner.
Goodbye.
You know it's bad when I become the leader.
You're in the middle.
You have the easiest job.
It is super chill in the middle.
This is really nice.
Walk the little catwalk.
Pause.
Nudge to the right.
And I think bow might have to...
I'm not sure about bow.
But we just got to move right while moving forward.
To counteract the fence.
Just don't overcompensate too much.
Just do it perfectly and you'll be fine.
Yeah.
Walk the catwalk.
No!
Doki!
I walked!
I went up!
I swear to god!
My hands are getting greasy from the sweat.
Okay.
We should do a pancake flip and make Doki have to be sentenced to seem just exactly the kind of hell that bow is.
Maybe you'll sing a different tune.
Go to bow's house and take her spot right now.
Play on your computer.
Oh yeah!
I got pushed off!
I got pushed off by the fence!
That's karma.
That's fucking karma right there.
I made it.
You know what?
I'm coming over there!
I'm taking you down!
Doki, I'm taking you down!
Yeah!
I say we let Doki do the fan.
Doki, you do the fan.
Yeah, let's do it!
Let's do the fan!
That's right!
I'll do it!
Okay, okay.
Wait a minute, Marty.
Pause the corner.
You guys are so fast!
Okay, okay.
Switch again.
Rotate.
Nudge to the corner.
I like how I end up basically in the same lane.
And then left.
Walk the little catwalk.
Doki, you're going too fast.
No!
Yeah, it's not so easy back there, is it?
Oh my god!
Shut up!
Nudge to the corner.
Walk a mile in someone else's shoes.
This is great.
To the corner.
That's not so easy over there, is it, Doki?
It is so easy!
This is fabricated.
Okay.
Farming street mallards.
To the corner.
Pause.
Okay, then go to the left a little bit.
Walk the tiny catwalk.
Nudge to the right.
Now walk the big catwalk.
You got that, Doki.
You got that.
I saw the first time.
I saw the exit.
I saw it.
I saw the light.
I know.
To the corner.
You're going to walk a little bit.
Now wait a minute.
I know.
Maybe both Val and Doki are the problem.
The problem!
No!
I think we've established the weak link on this one.
That's easy to say for the middle people.
Yeah.
The middle people think they have all of it.
We aren't.
The middle people are district one and then we're all on.
Of course.
Of course the middle people think it's so hard.
You guys even said earlier it's real cozy in there.
I'm sorry, I can't carry it.
You are too rich and comfortable in the middle.
I'm a key holder, so I think you should cater to me.
Do we still need to flip every time?
Why don't we just go down a single one together?
No, because we need to push the buttons.
We need to push the buttons.
Wait, I know which button though.
But there is buttons everywhere.
I thought there was just one that was the right button.
I'm pretty sure they all need to be pushed.
That's very reasonable.
The corner and then pause.
We're regressing.
Slowly inchworm up.
To the corner.
Wait for your friends.
Hold them off.
Let them go.
Wait, wait.
Okay, inch to the left.
Go up, go up.
Let's go.
Wait, wait.
A little bit to the right.
Okay, go, go, go.
Try your best.
Hold each other up.
No!
Doki.
I got Doki.
I got the middle.
You know what?
I think it was the middle people.
The middle people pulled me.
It was sabotage from the people in the middle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Excuse me?
I'm just chilling.
I'm not participating in this nonsense.
Wow.
I'm only going too fast.
I think you just pulled me.
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah, you pulled me in Juniper.
You pulled me in a sneeze for one minute.
Holy shit.
Holy.
All right, here we go.
This is the time.
Synchronization.
What's your friends?
What's your fellows?
Left.
Okay, and left.
Wait.
And up, girls.
Let's go.
Yeah.
And to the right.
And to the left.
And to the right, girls.
Girls, you're fucking dead.
That was my first sniff.
I was like, I get one!
I get one!
All right, here we go.
It's day 335.
Bro!
I've been here for 300 days!
I'm here for 300 days.
Why is this not randomized?!
But she pulls the bullies.
Just pull me across, please.
Everything else was randomized, but now this one decides not to be.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait on the buttons, wait on the buttons.
Okay, get into position.
Positions?
Yeah.
Positions, girls?
Okay, go girls.
Go girls, go girls.
No!
I'm sorry!
I got pulled to the left!
I actually made it!
Okay, here we go.
Okay, this is it, I believe.
So cursed.
Alright, let's go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Up you get, up you get, up you get, wait.
Up you get, up you get.
Left, left, up you go, up you go, up you go, up you go.
Buttons, keys.
Okay, butt to the right, line up.
Everybody ready, and go.
Go girls, go girls, go girls.
Ain't no way.
Should we stop flipping?
Maybe we should stop flipping.
Okay, go ahead, Vi, it's your turn.
Yeah, we're gonna turn into our normal size.
Up you get in honor.
Go, go, go.
Go, girl.
This is probably a pain issue.
And wait.
Left girl.
Yeah, it's probably, yeah, yeah.
And buttons.
Yeah, yeah.
And buttons and right.
And buttons.
I did not...
I just don't...
I think, I think the right side's just cursed.
I think.
By the way...
You put the right side and you put the left side.
But I was like no, I tried it once, I'm good, now.
Okay.
When you get it, I'm gonna let you get it.
Don't rush to the door.
Don't rush to the door so quickly.
I think that'll pull up the people.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As the middle, I just wait for the ends to go up.
I don't know if it's better to pull them, but I just kind of like sit down.
No, don't pull the ends to pull.
I just do this.
I just inch up.
Yeah, if you're in the middle, take your time.
Must be nice to have that privilege.
Yeah, right?
No!
Noooooo!
Noooooooo!
Hmm.
It's okay.
If we keep doing it, eventually it'll work.
I think we need to call out our steps.
One, two, step.
Three, two.
It's like rotating.
We're gonna be a row team, guys.
we're gonna be a row team, guys.
Row.
Sink.
Everybody sink.
Get into your row computer.
Doki, you're too far.
There we go.
Okay, and go.
Go!
I did it!
You did it, Doki!
I made it across!
This is the worst game ever made.
Alright, wait for everybody and off we go.
Girls, let's do it again one more time.
No, girls!
Don't forget those smiles!
And up, up, and hit that button, hit that button!
And one, and two, and three, and four!
I'm gonna go fuck the lawn washers in 30 minutes!
Don't forget the smile!
If you are finding yourself pulling ahead, fall back, keep an eye on the rope in general, that's very good.
And to the left, and then you go up, and you go up, and up, and up, and up, and you hit that button!
And then you move right, and then you go and forward!
Forward!
Big smiles everybody, big smiles!
Big smiles!
Don't go to the door!
We got two!
Big smile, big smile!
Not yet!
I'm doing television aerobics!
We're back to the 80s!
And one, and two, and stretch!
Right for the sky!
We're back to the 80s, guys!
We need aerobics tape to get us through!
Okay, what's this?
What the fuck is this?
Speedrun!
You have to be between...
In between?
Yeah, greater than...
So don't press the buttons yet!
Less than two seconds, or almost three, I guess.
Where the fuck am I?
Go!
Press, press, press, press, press!
Stuffy!
Stuffy's AFK!
Oh, I was looking at the wrong guy!
I'm like, wait, I already hit it!
Yeah!
And...
Oh!
Wow!
Wow, okay.
We gotta be right on top of it.
Oh my god.
Oh, it changes!
Wait, no, it doesn't change.
No, it doesn't.
No, we're just too slow.
It's our total!
It's our total.
So just like, run on top of it.
Oh, wait.
Okay, okay.
Just run on top.
Alright, once it starts.
And... go.
Oh my god!
This is actually awful.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we have to be like, up to it.
I wish I had a countdown.
We have to all be like around 30.
Oh, I'm sorry.
We're too close.
Oh, fuck.
Sorry.
Oh, oh.
Oh, shit.
What?
Go!
Why was I waiting so long?
We were so close!
We were so close.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
What?
The timer has to start going.
We have to be like, let's like, scoot up to it.
Scoot up to it, too.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go.
Oh, I'm saying I'm...
Yeah!
Link, I was like, staring at you.
I know.
Me too!
You guys are our drivers, jeez.
Literally not even blinking.
Not even breathing.
No.
Ready.
Steady.
Number two.
All I learned is Pico Park and breathing.
What's this?
Wait, what's this?
I don't know.
Oh, I think the, the, it's gonna like, rock it.
Yeah.
Oh, we have to time it correctly.
Okay, so like, you have to hit the block.
Oh, I see, I see.
So like...
Okay, hold on.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to move.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Oh.
Oh, it's a little too early.
A little too early.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I'll use the countdown in game.
Ready?
Yeah.
So close!
Just push it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Give me a sec.
Alright, I'm ready.
You need to be, like, up there.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh, wait, okay, I didn't realize we were starting.
Let's try it again.
Okay.
Two, one.
Ah, so close!
So close!
So close.
Alright.
Three, two, one.
How do I get over there?
Okay, there we go.
Oh!
Wait, how do we go?
How do we even leave it?
Yay!
The last person needs help.
We need the block.
Yeah, we actually do need it.
We have to do it.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna push it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Forget using your brain, Dee.
Just freaking throw your head against the cliff.
Can you jump on the box for it?
Like, is the box enough?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I think it is.
You just have to fall off and then you can...
Maybe you have to time it.
Maybe you two should try the mid-air collision thing and just fall into the...
Yeah, collide with each other.
Okay.
Let's collide.
Do the countdown.
You guys are gonna do the countdown, yeah.
Okay.
We didn't need that before.
Three, two, one.
Wait, my one or your one?
Oh, sorry.
Three, two, one.
No way.
Okay, okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh, no!
No, you're good for me.
I'm trying.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Stop!
Nailed it.
Wait, maybe I can like...
Maybe jump across it.
Jump across it.
I'll come out.
It's not gonna work.
It's not gonna work here.
What am I...
Alright, okay, okay.
Sorry, sorry.
Three... Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Timer in game.
Yeah, true.
Three, two, one.
Go.
You can hear the keyboard.
You can hear the button mashed in.
Oh, my God.
It grows longer.
What?
Ew.
What the hell are we?
Oh, we have to get the baseball.
We have to get the baseball and bounce it to the cross.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Christ.
What the fuck?
You have to be shorter.
Your ears have to be a little shorter.
I think you have to start...
Do you have to start short so it can bounce all the way up?
Maybe.
I don't know.
Oh!
If you start short, I think it bounces harder.
Okay.
I give up.
Wait, wait, wait.
Grow.
Grow as it hits you.
Or maybe we should make like a ladder up to it and catch it from there so that it doesn't bounce as hard.
Maybe we should go all the way back up to the top.
Oh, you jump.
You jump as it hits you.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
I got it.
Oh, maybe not too...
There we go.
Yeah, we have to jump.
We have to jump.
Okay, so move up, move up, move up more.
We need to get further.
Yeah, we need more.
Why are you taking my spot?
I'm sorry.
I'm such a fuck up.
Ball guys.
Juni, you should spread out because you're not hitting it.
You're right.
I know.
I just...
Okay, okay.
Get out of here.
Get out.
So we don't capture it?
There we go.
No, no, no.
You just jumped.
I'm sorry.
How do you...
Stop.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
You got it.
I was hoping it would be all you.
Sorry.
I'm a little flat.
Oops.
Okay, guys.
We can figure this out.
Bao and I got the system in.
Okay.
Yeah, you don't even move.
We're still figuring out our area.
I pressed up.
I pressed up, but it didn't work.
Oh.
Maybe I need to go shorter.
Guys, we need that momentum.
We need that momentum there.
Someone's not jumping.
Emily, you gotta jump.
You gotta jump.
I hear no jumping.
Oh, oh, oh.
No!
Oh, wait.
Who keeps growing higher?
Stop growing.
I'm just so much bigger.
She's getting excited there.
I'm trying to give you guys some air.
Bao and I are just...
We got a system going in.
I'm just chilling.
I'm mad chilling.
We need to get nice and high.
We're so chill now.
No!
Nice and high.
Maybe, Juniper, grow your ears a little bit.
Okay, I will.
Yeah, you gotta be a little bit...
Oh!
No!
You need more height when it gets to me.
You need taller.
Yeah, more high.
Oh, so close!
Okay, maybe a little taller?
Yes, taller.
This is so fun.
We look like a xylophone.
Okay, that's a little too tall, yeah.
Yeah, I know.
Oh, no!
Oh!
I'm gonna go crazy.
Oh, I'm gonna go fucking bananas!
Oh, sorry.
I tried jumping.
We probably need to get, like, progressively higher.
So...
If you're smaller than the one on your right...
I'm getting highway hypnosis.
I'm as tall as I can go.
What's highway hypnosis?
Oh!
No!
Where did we get it?
Oh, get off the person's head, yeah.
Grow on the head.
There you go.
Grow me.
Grow on the head.
Dude, where are we?
You must answer my riddles.
I am the troll.
Under the bridge.
You must be the troll.
Okay, stop trying to take my key, Dokie.
Stop trying to take my keys.
I'm literally just standing there!
Boo!
Hey, the troll tall.
I'm putting it up here so you can't grab it, okay?
There we go.
Nice.
We did it.
We did it, guys.
Yay!
That was a fun mechanic.
Yeah, that was a crazy mechanic there.
What are we?
We're just Pico.
We're Picos.
We're Picos in a park.
Pico Park!
What?
What did you do?
All I did was jump!
Okay, so don't jump.
Don't jump.
Oh, until we get there.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, guys.
Okay.
Alright, no, I got it.
Don't jump.
Oh, sorry.
What was that?
Don't jump.
Can you, like, suspend yourself by, like, spamming jump?
Probably not.
Probably not, no.
Yeah, you have to touch it first.
Wait, is there enough room?
Okay, there's enough room.
Yeah, you gotta...
What do we do here?
Oh, we have to land on each other!
On each other's heads!
Do we?
Yeah!
Wait, what?
I think we land on each other's heads.
On each other's heads?
Yeah, yeah, we can build a ladder, try it.
Like back here?
Yeah, try jump up.
Yeah, yeah, and then jump down into the person's heads.
Yeah, see?
Okay.
Yeah, and then...
Come up here.
And then we all jump down to you, guys.
I don't think that's how that's gonna work.
No, trust me!
I don't know about that one.
No, no, it works!
Cause then we build a ladder!
You can't jump though, right?
Yeah, you can't jump if someone's on your head.
So how are we gonna go the other way?
The other person that makes it at the top will be a ladder.
And then they'll be closer to the...
It's the ladder system!
We can just do that.
We can just start it from the bottom though.
Yeah, like that!
No, we don't do that here.
We can just start like that.
But we can start it like this way.
So we don't have to do it upside down.
We can just drop.
Go to the right normally.
And then ladder!
Okay, now we stack.
Now we're stacking.
Stack!
And then you jump down?
You guys need to drop like a bat.
A family of opossums.
Oh, okay.
That was weird.
I need space to...
Okay, there you go.
You can space it down.
And then we ladder.
Everybody move to the right.
Stretch a little bit.
Very careful.
It's not enough.
Trust me!
Trust the process!
It is enough!
We just need shimmy a little bit more.
Do we have to jump at an angle?
Oh no, you can't.
You can't, yeah.
No, we just need to all shimmy just a little bit.
If it works, trust the process.
You cannot move when you're jumping though.
Yeah, you can't move when you're jumping.
We all just need to shimmy a little bit more.
We didn't trust her, bros.
Trust the process!
Spieve.
Nobody even tried it!
We did try!
We did!
We just fell to our death on accident.
Oh my god.
Dude, my ping was like 130 right there.
Okay.
Dude, I'm lagging actually though.
Like, my stream is dying.
I'm lagging.
I've lost the plot, fellas.
Oh, um...
Stacking.
Did you disconnect?
Oh, you said thank you.
I'm going through.
No, we don't stack yet.
We stack after...
I can't go down.
Juniper go down, then Amelie on top.
On top of each other.
You're right, you're right.
Okay, and then...
Go down.
And then bow.
And then me.
And then Doki.
And then we just...
Right, as much as you possibly can.
Everyone...
Take us back, take us back, take us back!
As far as I can go.
Great.
Here we go.
Just don't fall, just trust the process.
Just trust the process.
I'm holding on with my pinky toe here.
Just go over a little bit, yeah.
You need me to go a little further.
I need, I need Steffi Higo a little bit.
Look at me on Juniper's head.
Okay, wait, what?
Yes!
The process has been trusted!
Now we all need to be on this.
We all trusted the process.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
All but one.
Guys...
Okay, good job.
Wait, no!
No!
Oh no!
Small panic.
Everybody started panicking and then I started panicking!
I thought we were gonna jump off.
There were spikes coming.
Okay.
Even got the button.
Okay, on top of each other, one by one.
One by one.
Okay, back.
Here we go again.
Back.
Back at it again.
Gotta wait until you're on solid.
Toki?
I'm losing my mind.
That was all me, baby.
It didn't even matter.
You just got picked up by an alien tractor beam.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
It's a small world music, kind of, which is why we're doing this.
Six!
I want Rainbow Water!
All right.
Ladder time.
I'm a formation.
Are you good?
I think you're good.
Go get me.
I'm good.
Oh my god, that's literally one pixel.
Oh, she needs to move over?
There we go.
Easy peasy, tons of room.
All right, don't move.
Don't move?
Okay.
Yay!
This one I'm scared.
I'm going to sit on this side, so I can jump off and hit the button.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
But I may die to ping.
Oh, wait!
Oh, you're gonna go...
Okay.
Bye!
Oh, Sophie!
You might actually have to do that because of the spikes.
But where do we go?
Wait, wait, wait.
We're stuck now.
Wait, come back, Sophie.
Wait, let me come back.
Just jump off.
Does that not count?
Okay, there we go.
Wait, why would they put this platform right below you guys if we weren't supposed to touch that?
I don't know.
Maybe a safety measure.
But we can't move anymore.
Too many people died.
Too many people left.
There has to be a solution.
Do the jump, it'll be so funny.
I think we softlocked.
The solution is not to jump on my head when we are going across, I guess.
Yeah, don't jump off.
Yeah, only one person jump.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay, we love this level.
Let limes be at the edge.
And no one stack on her.
Yeah, yeah.
Voltron form!
I need, I need...
Yeah, don't stack yet.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Trust it.
I think you're good.
I might have been good.
Oops, sorry.
It's okay, we try again.
We, we do.
We try.
No, no, no, no.
We are in contact with you.
Um.
Up.
Ah.
No.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Go back, go back.
Oh, shi- Oh, no.
Oh, I guess we're not.
Oh, no.
Yeah,
sorry, sorry.
Like...
I think we're not here anymore.
Oh, yeah.
I don't think so.
Where no one is there, but it's just...
We gotta lock it, guys!
We gotta lock it!
We literally just had to...
Okay.
Everything is fine.
Okay, get to the end before we start staggering, because otherwise lag shit fucks up.
Alright, I'm at the end.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, I think you're good now.
That's fine, that's good.
Trust the process, there we go.
Yeah, yeah.
It gives you a little bit of a wiggle room.
Okay.
Yay!
Everyone get near me so that we don't accidentally lose anyone.
Okay, ready?
It's gonna have to be Juniper that jumps off now.
Yeah, Juniper, I believe in you.
Okay, I can do it.
I can do it.
I mean, we could drop in a way that makes slime.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't worry.
Okay.
I can handle this.
I'm worried, I'm worried, I'm worried.
You guys all just need to...
Wait.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
No, like one person can stay there.
One person can stay there because...
Yeah, one person can stay.
Just we need to like coordinate that.
You know what?
Since you're gonna jump I will jump too.
Okay.
I know.
Oh, it's right there.
Kiko Park endurance.
We're so good.
I love this game.
Yay!
Do the jump.
Do it.
Jump.
I think you're good.
Jump!
Okay, you're sure?
Okay.
Trust.
It's like very forgiving.
We're just chilling.
Alright, I'm going to put myself back here so that I can jump.
Yeah, good idea, good idea.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
And then I'll stay.
I'll stay here.
Yeah.
I'm just chilling.
Okay.
Alright.
Three, two, one.
Okay, careful.
It's gonna start like as soon as...
Yeah.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Now, don't think we can drop.
Okay.
And then we can drop?
Yeah, then we can drop.
Oh, no, no, no.
Don't drop too soon.
Oh.
We have to like...
That was me.
We have to coordinate.
I forgot.
You're good.
It's okay.
I forgot.
I love this game.
I love my friends.
We're doing so good.
Oh, sorry.
First try, guys.
First try.
This is the run.
It wasn't that last one.
It's this one.
Shake off those...
Come on, we got this.
We are gamers.
We do this every day.
Don't ladder until everyone on top.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
My turn.
You lost your privilege.
Okay, now we can.
Okay, now we wait for the ledge.
Now we escape to the ledge.
I have to stay behind.
Unless you...
Snuffy, you gotta do the jump.
Snuffy, I trust you.
Snuffy, you got this.
You have to do that jump over there.
She doesn't even know.
If you wanna stay up there, move right and don't jump.
I'll do it.
I'll do the jump.
Win this thing.
Do not move.
There you go.
Did you see that?
Nobody move.
Do not jump.
Jump.
What happened?
You were all for it.
I even had people with this thing.
I forgot about the spikes.
I think we can get pretty close to the spikes.
Don't ladder yet.
Do not ladder yet.
I'm sorry.
There was no broom.
Don't fucking ladder.
We kind of look like condiments on a hot dog.
Why is it this level?
Why is this level?
What do I jump for?
I am just a kid.
Everyone just stack straight.
And now we get to the ledge.
And now we ladder.
Ladder time.
You are safe.
Don't worry.
You are very safe.
Big smiles.
I think if we stack here, like three and three, we will be able to walk off easier.
Maybe.
Let's do it.
One of us still has to press the button though.
I will press the button.
I will do it.
Everyone fall to the right.
Wait, can you...
Oh, bye.
It's fine.
We have one person.
Yeah, there we go.
Now jump off.
What?
What happened?
I feel like we can't just jump off and say I'm jumping off.
You have to be like, okay, let's go.
Let's jump on three or something.
Don't just jump off.
No shit.
That's what's happening.
We need a 3-2-1.
The power of the 3-2-1.
We cannot 3-2-1 because there's fucking spikes.
Meow.
Meow, meow, meow.
I'm so sorry.
I can't sing it anymore.
I know.
I'm so stupid.
I'm gonna do it, guys.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it right now.
Do it.
Oh shit.
I didn't mean to.
I didn't mean to actually.
Meow, meow, meow.
I can't.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna push Ollie.
Meow, meow.
I'm gonna do it.
Please have mercy.
Ladder.
Ladder tower.
Does that thing fucking rubber band horribly for anybody else?
No, it's just you.
It's just your fin.
I'll play.
I can't do the jump if I'm up here.
I'm sorry.
Guys, I'll do the jump.
Watch this.
I got this.
Witness me.
I'm dropping.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I was a little bit early.
I'm practicing my jumps right now.
I can't even laugh.
It hurts.
This is the level that breaks us right now.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna push Amelie.
This is the mind break level.
Oh shit, I almost actually ran into that.
On the plus side, I'm...
Oh no, actually no, I'm in a really bad position to do the button again.
So...
It's okay, I believe.
We can all do it.
I got this.
You got this.
It's scary, I know.
I could go over here.
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Don't be on my head.
I'm witnessing, I'm witnessing.
Okay.
Everybody...
Go!
Go, go, go!
We did it.
The key is on the other side.
That's easy to get though.
We're free.
Don't move.
That's all it took.
Don't jump.
Oh my god!
We did it!
Yeah!
Skittles are divisible!
Skittles!
Oh my god.
Parkland!
Let's go!
Everybody, let's play some Suckerball!
What is this?
What is going on?
Don't get hit!
It's Toto!
Toto!
It's bullet hell!
I have this corner.
I call left.
Far left.
I love Undertale.
Remember that the edges are spikes and they'll kill you.
Guys, we just have to live for 20 seconds.
I'm grazing, I'm grazing.
I'm gonna bomb.
Oh, that's a big ball!
Giant Damaku!
It's okay.
Don't hit the edge!
I can't even make any sound.
I'm just full of despair.
This is so easy!
Easy game!
Easiest Touhou of my life.
Can they all be that easy?
Yeah.
Everything in retrospect is gonna look insane now.
This is just a moving platform.
This is level one, guys.
We're not...
Oh, guys!
Guys!
Guys, we must share.
This is sad.
Be kind to your fellow neighbors.
Let's go.
Thank you.
Think about your neighbors.
No, no, no!
Why up Amelie?
She couldn't be on top of me.
She was like in a bad place there.
Going down, going down.
Going down, down.
I'm directing Amelie.
We have to be in track.
Watch out!
I can't move!
Okay.
If Amelie's at the corner, it's safe.
I can't move.
I couldn't move.
Whoever's in the middle, you must direct.
You must unite together.
Okay.
I'm up.
Amelie is so dead.
I couldn't go any more down.
There was nowhere to go.
It's okay.
We can keep doing this.
Think of your neighbor.
Snuffy?
There was nowhere to go.
I was gonna die on the bottom or die in the middle.
There was nothing to do.
We gotta give bottom person a lot of space too.
Thread the needle.
I don't think two people can fit through that one.
No, they cannot.
I'm trying to give you room.
I saw her.
I went to the bottom.
Look at how bottom I am.
Up, up, up.
He touched my ass.
You cannot have two on the bottom either.
It needs to be four top and one in the middle.
Maybe.
I can top four people.
I couldn't.
You could not do that.
It's so hard to see.
Up, up, up.
She can't fly.
I'm all the way up.
Separate.
Four.
I need to go down.
I'm up.
I'm in the middle.
I need to go down.
I'm up.
How do we pass the key that much?
Wow.
From the bottom to the top.
That's crazy.
This one is not so bad though.
Yeah.
I'm getting the hang of it.
The randomized positions are kind of beans.
I think we just kind of needed the spacing.
Oh, I think we got the hang of it now.
Yeah, we're figuring out how the hitbox is.
V2 versus depth perception.
Because it's the movie.
Oh, goodbye.
I got what I brought.
The bottom to the bottom in the beginning, I think.
It's the same map, no?
It's the same one, yeah.
It's just randomized.
Alright, now four and one in the middle.
Oh.
No, it's five up, one in the middle.
Sorry, five up.
Going down.
Alright, five up, one in the middle.
Five up, one in the middle.
Alright, now we go down.
We go down.
Go down.
Meow, meow, meow.
Down, down, down.
These ones move, these ones move.
Be careful.
Give me room.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
I
am just a kid.
I couldn't move.
Bailey fits my man.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Okay.
Alright, now five.
One in the middle.
Five, one in the middle.
Okay.
Down, down.
Ow, ow, ow.
Stupid.
I was so busy.
Oh, fuck.
That's my baddest.
I've gone down.
Sorry.
Okay.
I don't think it's three here.
Yeah.
Okay, now five up and one in the middle.
Okay, now down.
I'm scared.
No.
Okay.
I'm not used to being at the very bottom.
It's okay.
Up, up, up.
Alright, five.
One in the middle.
Five.
God, I'm bitching.
Alright, down, down, down, down, down.
Down a little.
Down a little for me.
Alright, up.
I'm going up.
Alright, I'm threading the needle.
Down, down, down, down.
I'm going, I'm going.
I'm threading the needle.
Alright, everybody.
Every man for themselves.
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
Guys, I don't think that was it.
Guys, I don't think that we should have every man for themselves.
I don't know how to judge.
I don't know.
How do I just let go?
Just let go.
It's over.
Alright, five up.
One in the middle.
Alright, down, down a little.
Down, down, down.
Please more down.
Okay, we're fine.
Thread the needle.
No, you're gonna get hit.
Sorry, I did not thread the needle.
Thread the needle.
What happened to the thread?
My depth perception.
Versus depth perception.
That's true.
More beautiful.
Five up.
One in the middle.
Down, please.
One up a little.
Thread the needle.
Nice.
Down, down.
I'll thread the needle.
Every man for themselves.
Wait.
No!
What do you mean no?
Oh.
That was a horrible scream.
I thought we were gonna crash into the wall.
I was just really happy we finished.
I just wanted to stay there so long.
I thought you should have crashed into the wall like Corpse Pride or some shit.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
No, no.
I'm not ready.
You cannot pee.
Okay, she's peeing.
Guys, she's peeing.
She's doing the forbidden piss.
What if she just actually makes it through without moving?
No way.
That would be crazy.
Nice.
Oh, no.
It keeps restarting.
We're just gonna be here forever.
It's okay.
It's practice.
I'm gonna look at Twitter.
You guys enjoy that practice.
I'm grazing.
Nothing's gonna hit that forever.
This is not randomized.
She'll always hit those.
I'm bombing.
I need to check my For You page.
No damn way.
Chat.
Where am I?
How many worlds left are there?
We still have the battle realm level.
Oh, hell no.
I think someone said though something.
Unlock after we beat the game.
Yeah, we can't beat the game because of the flashbang though.
I think like one per...
I have to beat it by myself to unlock it.
Or something.
So the flashbang would be gone.
We're actually in hell.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I wanna use the bathroom now.
We take a potty break.
Alright, let's all use the bathroom.
I'm using the bathroom.
I swear.
After I leave, I swear to god.
Okay, I will do the same thing.
Potty break, potty break.
Everybody potty.
What just happened?
Oh, I guess it's just me and...
Is that Min?
No, I'm still here.
I'm gonna kill.
I figured if I enter zen zone, I won't hear the music anymore.
Yeah, me too.
At some point, I will find a headspace where the music just ceases to be.
I'll just sing it louder for you.
Do do do do do do do do do do do do.
You better fucking hope there isn't another ball collection level, Min.
I know.
Chat.
You just have better eyes than me because you don't go out in the sun, okay?
I have a vignette over my vision.
It's like a dark filter.
And it's like closing in.
Like my vision is tunneling the longer I stare at the game.
That's called locking in.
Do you mean like in video games where they symbolize losing your health by the world just kinda going black?
Yeah, no.
For real, on god, that is what's happening to me right now.
I've been staring like in the...
Beep boop beep boop boop.
Chat, where even are we?
I'd like to know what this music sounds like on a Genesis.
I think it'd sound great.
Make it a bit more farty.
Wait, so how many worlds do we have left?
I'm back.
It's like 15 total.
That was so fast.
So we have four left?
Four worlds, I guess.
Four worlds, and then how many levels are within those worlds?
Four.
Four each.
We're so close.
But I was like, we don't have much to go.
Oh god, we have so much to go.
We're so close.
We're zooming.
Wait, Snuffy is still gone?
Snuffy is still gone.
I'm mildly concerned.
Me too, I think.
I don't think she wants to come back.
Why is she making my story long enough to just end?
If I don't come back in 15 minutes, the class will leave.
I can't.
You can't have my spot, Doki.
Stop trying.
If your Snuffy is more than 15 minutes late, you can legally leave the collab.
This is my spot.
Oh yeah?
That's right, I die first.
I'm here!
I'm sorry.
I'm back.
I think we're waiting on Juniproductor.
Hi, welcome back!
Jopanar.
That's right, now you'll never get your spot.
Oh, Jopanar.
And Amelie.
Oh, Shpupupur.
Oh, Bububur.
We're almost there, guys.
We're so close.
What's the tech here?
What have you guys learned?
It's just die really fast.
You die faster from the walls than the middle.
Yeah, just go to the walls.
Just hug the wall and then it'll be over.
Letting Mint die over and over while I just look at my phone.
The electricity.
We're all here!
Let's go!
We're back!
Alright, let's go.
We got this.
Alright, this is real.
This is real.
This is real now.
This is my corner.
What's the difference between red and blue?
Nothing.
They're the same.
Blue is good.
Blue is not good.
I saw the blue.
I saw you eat two.
It's making me glow.
I'm like a snowman.
Oh my god.
The daddy.
Ah!
Michael died!
I fucked it.
Blue was not good, chat.
We haven't seen that part yet because Snuffy always died while he ate cake.
I know, yeah.
I never saw that.
It's true.
I was eating the blue dot.
Yeah, she took two of our lives from it.
She was like, blue is good, guys.
It tastes like blue raspberry.
Yeah.
It's true.
It's strawberry and blue raspberry.
Cold pull, yummers.
Alright, here it is.
Here's the thing we didn't get to see.
Then the blue ones disappear.
It's so easy.
Yeah.
Goodbye.
Okay, just go right.
Oh, that's a door, not a box.
Guys, 12 more seconds, guys.
12 more seconds.
One more life.
Guys, just chill.
It's fine.
We're chill.
Skyeeeey.
Oh that.
I told you.
Look at that.
I saw you look at the sparkling light there.
What does that do?
Yeah.
I didn't get to sample it.
You guys got to eat that all night.
Wait, don't jump.
Don't jump.
Do not jump.
Wait, find out a place to...
Don't kill us.
I was okay.
We got to eat nights, each and every time to...
Oh boy.
Okay, so it's never ending.
Okay, I'm staying in the middle.
Alright, this is my spot.
This is my spot.
There's two rounds!
Did someone just panic jump?
Okay, a bunch of people in the middle.
Two of us on the right.
This is randomized, too.
There's another one!
Left, left, left!
Move your big butt over!
Oh, we did it!
Two seconds!
But this is so difficult.
Guys, this is randomized, too.
Go all the way to the right!
I lived.
All I'm saying is that I lived.
Okay, a lot of people to the left.
Alright.
Why are you here, CJ?
I think that was one spot!
We all have one death.
That was my one.
That was your one death.
That was my one death today.
Oh, that was freaky.
Alright, we're all good.
Kissing.
Woah!
There's a lot of space on my end.
Yeah, Doki, I'm with you.
Oh, 15 seconds, guys!
Hi!
No,
I sacrificed myself for you!
I did.
I lived.
No!
I'm sorry!
You're so safe.
I was sentenced to death.
What were your crimes?
Go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go!
We need to spread out more so there's more room to move.
Even if you have a spot, we need more room.
Oh, okay.
This is weird.
I got it.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Alright.
There's so many.
There's a lot.
Help me!
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, fuck.
No pressure.
No pressure, by the way.
Thank you, though.
I'm on my own.
You guys, there's, like, so much room over here!
You still died!
I... I... I...
No, no!
I was giving rooms for everybody else!
Okay, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Not nice.
Beware of falling rocks.
Why don't they give us helmets?
We're okay.
Okay.
They should at least give someone, like, a little shield.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
This is so spacious over here.
I'm loving it.
Will we live?
15 seconds, guys!
There we go.
Yeah.
Oh, nice!
What the fuck?
No, we won't live here!
We won't!
What?
What the fuck happened there?
Why did all you guys bunch down?
No one would know!
That was mean.
That was cruel.
I shouldn't have been so against the wall.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
I stare at you like this.
Oh, we're competing against that hole there.
Yeah, I think we both had to move left there.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
My chat is mad at me.
They said I could jump on people.
No, you can't!
There's literally an electric balloon!
A balloon!
You guys saw Mint just pushing out.
Please!
Please, move!
I won't make it!
Give us space!
Mint begging for a life.
Door, stop!
Line, that one was unavoidable.
That one was rough.
That one was pretty rough.
I'm here.
This is as far as I can go.
Moving?
Yay!
There's only one spot here, so don't come over here.
No!
There was a fucking thread!
I was not used to threading the needle.
It was never my job.
Spread it out, spread it out.
We good, we good.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Can I have a little bit of space here, perhaps?
Okay.
Okay, man.
Move left, right.
That was close.
We don't have to come over here, guys.
Guys!
Why is it 30 seconds?
Thank you.
We almost did it.
We can do this.
We were so close, yeah.
Our reflexes are improving the longer we play.
Are they?
Yeah, yeah.
I feel like it's like a tango.
We both go opposite ways, and then we embrace each other.
Yeah, it's kind of awesome.
Okay, let's all go to the right.
You can double stack now.
You can double stack.
Oh.
Yeah, the laser just fucked off.
So you can double stack there.
I know.
I jumped off somebody's head, but then I just fucked off myself anyway.
We're gonna die.
In a second.
You need to move to the sides more, because sometimes there's just not enough room there.
Go, go, go.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
You.
Oh, okay.
Okay, this is safe.
I feel so safe here.
I feel so safe.
Moving left.
Nice, nice, nice.
I think the next one is when the...
Wow, please, a little to the left.
...is when the line disappears, right?
I can't, I can't.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I don't know where to go.
Doki's fat ass.
Fat ass.
Scoot over a little bit, Doki.
There we go.
No!
Once again, her fat ass.
Once again.
I don't think we should all...
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, thank god.
There's more space to the left.
There's so much space to the left.
Please, back up over here!
Okay, nice.
There's a lot of...
We're here still again.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Okay.
Let me stack, let me stack!
It's up to you, Belle.
Make room, make room!
It's up to you.
We're okay, we're okay!
No one's moving.
Someone's stuck!
No!
Oh my god.
We had it!
The last one!
It forces you to stack.
It forces you.
Left please, left please, left please!
Thank you.
Oh!
Please make room!
Not like this!
Belle!
Thank you.
I'm moving right.
We can fit three there if you scoot.
Thank you.
Oh my god, Juniper!
Juniper!
I'm gonna die.
Don't say that!
I'm stacking!
Why did you move?
You're saving your life!
I didn't trust you.
Sorry, I didn't trust the process!
It's okay.
Amma?
Yeah?
Oh my god, that was an amazing scream.
Thank you.
Stacking!
You don't have to stack, but if it's necessary, then you gotta be ready for it.
It's necessary.
I don't wanna play anymore.
I don't wanna...
My passenger princess!
Okay, okay, stacking!
Don't get in a line!
Get in a line!
Let's go!
How much more?
We have one...
Oh, we have two left, guys.
Guys, we have two left.
We might as well finish.
Okay, hold on.
Let me change my stream.
What the fuck?
I think we jump all together.
We're going on a...
I think whoever gets highlighted is the people who can jump.
And then some of us are darkened and sleeping.
See?
Some of us have, like, closed eyes.
So I think those who are light up have to jump.
I'm jumping.
Me too!
I'm jumping so much!
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump!
Jump, jump!
What the fuck?
Why do we suck at jumping?
I swear I'm spamming this shit.
The Battle Boss!
And it switches, so you gotta pay attention.
I think you just have to mash jump, honestly.
Is there a quiz called that?
Or is it, like, Flappy Bird and we're just keeping ourselves afloat?
I think that's highlighted.
Mash is the fuck out of jump.
Do we keep going up?
We do.
Okay, so just mash the shit out of it.
Mash!
Oh, I don't know.
I think it's gotta be in sync.
That sounds cool.
No.
No, no, no, no, no!
We can literally mash!
I don't think...
I don't think we can stay up.
I don't know.
Maybe it's just deceptive because we do have, like, four jumps, technically.
That's true.
But I don't think we do.
Okay.
Your turn, guys.
So we use this knowledge.
Knowledge used!
Knowledge!
I'm going!
Hello?
I will stop this car, I swear to God.
I will turn around!
Right now!
Oh, please.
Get us out of here.
This is the definition of, like, backseat driving.
I don't even know, bro.
Backseat!
What's happening?!
I don't even know...
You could do everything right.
What?
I think you guys have to land and then get your jumps back on that platform and then jump again.
Yeah, you can only jump once, I see, because your eyes closed.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Let it land.
No, no, no!
Yes!
No!
We had new jumping!
We just gotta let it fall!
Let it fall!
We have to stop!
Let it snow!
No!
Very nice.
Yeah.
Hooray.
We got this.
Are we there yet?
Yes, yes.
Are we there yet, guys?
No.
Okay, your turn, guys.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Team B, go!
Nice.
Okay, jump, jump, jump.
Jump, jump, jump.
Jump, jump, jump!
Yeah, it's good!
It's good!
We got so far!
That was so cool!
No!
This is so cool.
Why is this so long?
I know.
Okay.
Do-do, do-do.
I am a little flappy bird.
Okay.
What am I doing
Why can't we go?
Stop jumping!
Someone's not jumping!
Min, are you jumping?
I am jumping!
I didn't see your eyes closed.
Target them and make fun of them based on if their eyes are open or closed.
That's how you know if they're gaming.
Yeah, I saw Min's eyes wide open.
I was jumping!
Your eyes were closed!
What do you even know?
You can't even see!
I am jumping!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I saw those eyes.
You saw those eyes, right?
Look at my eyes.
My eyes are closing right now.
That means you don't even know.
Somebody's eyes are not closing.
Are we looking at the same?
Yeah, you see that closing?
Of course!
I didn't see them without washing.
Come on!
I know what's happening!
I don't know!
The colors don't look the same!
Alright.
It's all up to you guys.
Oh!
Whose eyes were open?
Highlighted!
Who's clicking the screen?
That's making it...
That makes us go faster.
Here we go.
I believe in us.
Oh, now you closed the eyes.
I did not see!
Jump!
Jump around!
Okay, okay, okay.
We're good.
Nice!
No jump!
Falling!
Hopping!
Hop, hop, hop!
Nice!
Falling!
Hop, hop, hop!
Oh, no!
Let's go!
I need no way, bro!
I need no way!
No way!
How do we die now?
Wait!
How do we die?
We are retried!
Where's the key, guys?
Guys?
What happened?
Where's the key?
Who dropped the key?
Yeah.
Okay.
It's okay.
We learn.
We're learning.
Two people, like, have to use theirs, and then the other two uses theirs.
Nice!
Very good!
There we go!
Don't jump!
Yeah!
Oh, thank God!
Oh, my God!
Beep!
All right.
Nice.
We did it.
I'm so proud.
We got our driver's license, guys.
Yay!
We got a parallel pipe.
Parallel park.
The seven of us.
That's like, it's like there's, oh no!
Oh, this is PTSD.
I'm gonna do it!
Fuck.
Ew.
We know what it does.
Oh, I definitely know what that does.
You don't know what it does!
It says don't press it!
That's exactly what you say if that was gonna shower somebody with infinite riches.
That's true.
No!
Don't press this, it would give you money.
Okay, five, four, three...
Guys, you guys can keep going.
I don't think we can stay.
This has to be sex.
Who goes on the bottom there, like in this little hole?
Anybody go on that hole down there?
You guys?
The little hole down here.
Oh, it just keeps going!
It just keeps going!
Alright, just keep moving, guys.
Keep moving.
The screen's gonna eat us.
You guys, last time I played with my friends, Chaz called this my waterloo.
Oh, no!
What's a waterloo?
We'd be like all the way, bro.
How do we do this?
Do we just keep stacking over here?
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, stack.
Stack as much as you can.
So...
What?
Why are we stacking?
I don't know why we're stacking.
Go!
Guys?
Goodbye.
We have to stack all the way up.
We have to stack and then just keep going down.
Keep going.
Yeah, because once someone jumps off, it starts moving...
Okay, that makes sense.
Yeah.
...moves back up.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh!
So how come you think they left a death button there?
That's totally gonna be relevant later, right?
Yeah, I think that's good.
No, it's definitely...
Alright, stack.
Stack and then we're gonna go down to the bottom, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Drop.
How much can we stack?
I don't think you want four.
Just keep going.
Just let it go.
Go?
Someone's gotta go.
Emily.
Okay, now...
That's it.
Goodbye.
You get...
Oh!
You don't die when you jump off it!
Oh, so we can put someone over there and then...
We would never put a tiny little hole there if it wasn't meant for something.
Yeah, I think...
Okay.
Okay, who jumped on top of...
Alright.
Oh, no.
Who boosted me into that button?
You can't push people.
Oh, no.
Let's find the bottom.
Du du du du du du.
Please let it end.
So should I go as the bottom person?
Should I go into this little hole?
I think we should go three stacks of three, and then one person goes in the bottom.
I shall go into the hole.
The hole is the goal.
Here we go!
Go in the hole?
Like that.
And then I fall out, and then I come back.
And then we're dead?
And then we're dead.
Awww, bye!
I'm confused.
Oh, shit.
Use Bowser!
Maybe we just have to do the watermill.
Just like a watermill.
Just like really smooth side.
Oh, that was... Wow, clean!
Thank you very much.
Nice, nice.
We all get one.
When's my turn?
No, except for you.
Oh, okay.
You already had your one.
Okay.
One to the top, go.
Oh, fuck.
I was too slow.
Wait, can't you guys just fall down the hole and come back?
Oh, yeah, that's true.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna die, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I guess that just means that even if one person passes, there's still a chance we can save it at the end, I think.
There has to be a reason why that notch is there.
Let me, let me, let me use the notch.
Don't, don't...
Okay, Val got two.
That's not fair.
She's not there.
Three hours into the game, I forgore.
That happened to me before, too.
Don't leave the platform.
Just stay on for a sec.
I wanna test something.
Okay.
Nope, fuck, I fucked it up.
Hold on.
Can you come back on?
Yeah, I'll come back.
Okay, cool.
No one move.
There's nothing between the platform and the hole.
Oh, like stopping it or something?
Yeah, yeah, we use our big head to stop it.
Oh, stop it.
Yeah, yeah, you're gonna jam your head in there.
Cause your head's made of solid rock, right?
It might not be the right way, but god damn it if we aren't using our heads.
This is it, Snuffy.
This is what your head is for.
Use your head, she said.
Okay.
Val, it's up to you now.
I'm your head.
Okay, don't worry, this is what my head is for.
This is what your dent is for.
Yeah, this is what my dent is.
Okay, here we go.
Go, go, go!
I knew it.
I knew my head was good for something.
Now we gotta stack here.
We gotta stack here our colors, I saw.
I'm on Amma.
Orange needs to come up.
I can't move.
Guys, guys.
Guys, what happened?
Oh my god.
Guys, guys.
We can't push.
It's okay, we know it's...
Bro, I'm dead.
I don't know anymore.
I won't say anything.
I'll say something.
Oh my god, you almost pressed the button.
But it's a five.
I'll say something.
Let's keep running, keep going.
We're running out of order.
Keep going, keep running.
Alright.
I'll use that big brain of yours.
No.
I have the experience, guys.
You got it, you got it.
Alright, everybody go.
Goodbye.
Sorry, it was.
It's a one time use.
My head is super soft now.
If only we were like a little slower.
Are we going to have to staircase those blocks?
Because we have to climb up to the key.
Yeah, I think we have to staircase those fucking blocks.
It's also over a giant ravine of like killing...
Yeah, yeah.
Is that so?
Nope.
Don't jump.
Wedge.
It's wedge now.
Get up.
Just jump on me.
Wow.
You gotta go.
Thank you.
Alright, here we go.
I'm trying to go.
Okay.
I'm on top of wedge.
Grey.
Grey, blue, orange.
Yep.
And then me, me, me, me, me.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Oh my god, you freaked me out.
Yellow, green.
Green.
Red.
Scoot over.
Scoot some.
Go push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push, push.
No!
We pushed too far.
Yeah, you gotta make a staircase.
You don't push it down.
There's a pink block.
Despite us not having eight people.
That's kind of funny.
I think it's the same order.
So grey always has to be in front.
Yeah.
Because I saw it was the same order.
Yeah, it was the same order.
No, I'm not pink.
I'm not pink.
I'm purple.
Wow.
My chat is waving me.
I'm not doing that.
Whoa.
Are you okay?
Jam successful.
Grey in front, remember.
Grey in front.
I'm here.
No, but it's still grey in front.
Wait, wait, wait.
Grey push first.
Do it first.
Don't line up.
I don't...
But it drops.
They drop.
We can't...
We can't push it too far.
I can't.
Don't have room.
Okay, green, come up.
Okay.
You pushed it too far.
Sorry, that was me.
I was trying to jump, but I pushed it.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
Okay, if I'm pink, then what's the top one, huh?
What's the top one?
I don't know.
It looks kind of pink to me.
It's more pink than purple.
It's not grey.
Oh, I have the experience.
We didn't stack at all.
That's fine.
Go, go, go.
We don't need the stack.
We just need my big head.
Go, go, go.
Where would we be without it?
Alright.
Okay.
Is grey on the bottom again?
No, it's orange.
No, it's me.
Orange, yellow, grey.
Don't push it too far.
I'm pushing it to here.
I'm blue.
Okay.
Purple.
Snuffy.
Alright.
Alright, don't... yeah.
No more pushing on the bottom.
Yeah, bottom's gotta jump up before the thing starts pushing you.
Alright, Doki, start moving.
Okay.
Alright, let's start moving.
Let's start moving.
Let's start moving, please.
Please.
Go, jump, jump.
Go, go, go.
Holy shit.
That was so close.
It was like touching your ass.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, chill out.
Chill out, dude.
Oh, I don't think... I don't...
I was not there.
I'm sorry.
I tried to have one second to take a water.
How dare you.
I know.
Yeah.
None of us are getting a break.
You're not getting a break.
Yeah.
Watch out here.
Don't move.
No jumping.
Okay.
Interesting.
We've got some platforms.
Okay.
Don't say... Wow, this looks so harmless.
I think... But no, if everybody gets off, how do we get back?
It looks so dumb.
Okay, we might have to back.
Okay, what if we back together?
Back, back, back.
Like, touch each other.
Back, back.
What do you mean back?
Back.
I'm stacking.
Oh, stack.
I thought you were saying back.
How do we get back?
We can all jump off, no?
If we all jump off, how do we get back?
Oh, maybe like at the far right, there might be something that might bring us back.
Maybe one person has to parkour it.
I don't think you can.
I don't think you can, yeah.
Yeah, it's too far.
Maybe there's something at the very far back because we didn't explore that far back yet.
I think we should make a little bit of a bridge and just kind of like maybe peek it.
Yeah, just see.
Yeah.
We won't fall back, but we can just kind of like...
See what?
Yeah, there has to be something over there.
There has to be something.
Jump!
We'll never know.
We'll never know what's over there.
Okay, so if we stack on top of each other, like at least three or four high, we can at least just jump off together, I think.
So we won't lose anybody.
She just never moves.
She never...
She disassociated.
I am.
At this point, I am.
She just goes and she decided.
Alright,
everybody run off.
Alright, let's see what's over there.
Exploring.
Oh, see?
Oh, we...
No!
What is this?
Guys.
How do we make it plus?
What the...
Oh, we're so fast!
Super speed!
Guys, one by one.
Personal responsibility.
At least here you don't...
Don't forget there's like spikes and stuff.
Yeah.
Okay.
Easy.
This is where we have to pay attention.
We had the practice.
Now it's the real deal.
Okay, Amelie, get closer.
Amelie?
Yeah, I'm a little scared guys.
No, no, don't worry.
You can hit us like a brick now.
Just smack into us.
Yeah, there you go.
Okay.
We're making a wall.
Oh my god.
Jump over, jump over now because you smacked into it.
There we go.
Jump over now.
I'm gonna jump over.
I'm gonna do it.
Okay.
Careful, careful.
We all know where the spikes are.
Oh!
Look at the speed.
I was trying to adjust.
It went through ramp.
I was like, careful guys, don't jump off.
It's okay.
At least we figured it out.
It's so fiddly and rubber bandy once you have the speed.
Like the game does not know how to like accommodate it.
What the?
Why did you do that?
How did you guys die like that?
What happened?
Wait.
My hand was not even on the keyboard.
I know.
I think you need to pay more attention, man.
I wasn't even on the keyboard.
I wasn't even scratching out.
She's scratching out.
I saw people move.
I thought we were doing it.
I can't even.
I made a big mistake.
She just left.
She's like, bye guys.
I panicked.
Okay, here we go.
Try again.
Don't do it, don't do it.
I'm going to wait for it to become a full stop.
Stop.
Okay.
Yeah, there we go.
Now we keep going.
Be careful, it's gonna all...
Why can't I?
Oh, sorry.
Go over here.
I'll just be here.
Doki gets a head start.
But we don't die here anyway.
It's fine, whatever.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
Sorry, Val.
Okay, there's...
These are the death.
The death.
Okay, use this as a way to stop.
Oh, I fucked up.
Just launch yourself.
You hit us.
The doors are open for you.
Come in for a hug.
Glomp us.
Free glomps.
XD glomps you.
Okay.
Corky.
I'm stacking.
So I don't have to do anything.
Wait for it to come to the full stop.
Beep.
And...
Go.
Oh, I can't move.
I can't move.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
It's all good.
I'm gonna go.
There it is.
Oh, my god.
Hold on.
I'm trying to correct.
Oh, my god.
Be careful.
This is...
What is going on?
I think Min's like ghostiness just like carried us cause she literally just floated on the floor.
Floated like three times.
What can I say?
I'm hacking the game.
Devs is watching.
Good.
I hope they are.
I hope they are and take the game off Steam.
Yeah.
Now we're fast.
I don't know about you guys but as soon as we go fast like the camera starts like rubber banding back and forth.
It's awful.
Oh, my god.
No.
This level is fucking horrible.
We go again and again and again and again and again and then we'll master it.
Again.
No.
I love it.
Again.
Try again.
Full stop.
Couple more levels.
Alright, we're at our station.
Again.
Yay.
Off we go.
Button that turns you into a bug.
Here we go.
Alright.
Use it as a wall.
Use the wall.
Build a wall for the other people.
Build the wall.
We have our net coming in.
It's like a safety net.
Just jump from that.
Use that as a jump.
Use that.
Come on.
Okay.
I'm looking away from the spikes.
None of us will hit the spikes now.
What do you mean?
Like that.
It's like a barrier.
I don't think that's how that works.
It will change the camera though.
It's kind of working actually.
I am the wall.
How about you?
We need more room.
Are you going to make this?
I don't know.
This is going to be interesting.
You can make it.
Don't choke.
There you go.
Look at that.
And then we have to jump back here.
We don't have to jump on the panel.
Just jump over it.
Don't hit the button at the end.
Do I have to go?
Yes.
Jump over the spikes.
It's your turn.
No pressure.
Now the sand is going to make you go extremely fast.
Extremely fast.
Go only right.
Do not go left.
Oh my god.
I need you guys to move the camera guys.
I'm sorry.
Oh no.
Somebody has to grab the key.
There you go.
I got it.
Move left.
This is the barrier.
Doki.
I got you.
Oh my god.
I was going to throw up.
I swear to god.
I'm holding it in.
I'm having a hard time.
Oh my god.
What the fuck.
I literally went to take a freaking swig of water.
I dropped it.
And then it just started pouring into the vent on my floor.
I hope that's fine.
I hope that's okay.
There's no water breaks there.
Wait.
I've got water everywhere.
It's pouring into the vent.
Is that bad?
Free humidifier.
Yeah.
Now you have a humidifier.
Oh my god.
Please guys.
I can't.
I'm all the way at the back.
I can't do anything.
Someone needs to go up.
Someone needs to move up first.
It pushes us.
We just move automatically.
You just need to jump.
Yeah.
Skill issue.
What does the button do?
You just have to be really quick to jump.
How come the button says a plus?
It makes us faster.
It's the same thing as before.
It's not as fast though because I don't feel it.
I'm not really feeling the sensation.
The high isn't hitting me.
You can't jump on top of me.
I'm sorry.
I jumped up once to test it.
Why are you on top of us?
Why do you think I can slow it down?
I was testing.
You've already tested it.
It has to be like a frame perfect jump.
Why is this so difficult?
I think I actually have to go.
I said I was going to stay here for three hours.
What the fuck?
It's our turn.
We were so close.
Part 3.
Are we going to do a part 3?
We're so close to victory.
Let's go.
Part 3.
We have to synchronize.
Thank you guys.
We're safe.
We're free now.
Freedom.
Part 3.
The finale.
GG's.
We have...
We have part 3.
That was exhausting.
Go through the seizure part by herself.
I'll complete that part so we can lock the shadow area.
That's the true endurance.
The true endurance.
Is that completely a dark or something?
We would just drag you down, you know?
This should all be you.
GG's, guys.
I'm so happy to play four hours of Pico Parque.
You did so good.
There's no group I would rather suffer with.
I'm so excited.
I love a test of teamwork.
It's so satisfying.
Yay.
Bye, everybody.
Bye, guys.
GG's.
Bye.
Oh my god.
I'm so tired.
I'm so...
By the way, guys.
I didn't say anything earlier.
But I'm sick right now.
I'm sick.
But I powered through.
I have a sore throat.
Like, my throat is, like, really fucked up at the moment.
It's, like, sore.
So, like, you know how, like, when you know you're starting to get sick.
And then, like, your throat starts feeling super sore.
And a little pain.
That's me.
But that was really fun.
We actually made a lot of progress.
We made a lot of progress.
Even though, like, um...
Even though, you know, it was...
We still made progress.
We still made a lot of progress.
I'm proud of it.
We literally have, like, two more...
Two more... three more stages left.
And then we'll be finished.
But thank you, everybody, for coming.
I'm gonna go sleep now.
I'm gonna get some fucking meds.
And then take my meds.
And then...
And then go sleep.
I'm not, like, sick-sick yet.
But, like, I'm starting to get sick.
Like, you know, like, when you can feel your throat getting sore.
And you're like, Oh, that's the sign.
That's the sign where it's gonna hit soon.
Um, but...
Yeah, I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna fucking go sleep.
So I can get better as fast as I can.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.